nun habt der Bundesfinanzminister in
seiner einbringungsrede gestern
interessanterweise genau auf diesen
Sachverhalt und auch weitere große
Risiken der nächsten Jahre hingewiesen
hinter dem Horizont so hat er gesagt
auch wenn er heute morgen nicht anwesend
ist warte ein großer Eisberg auf den wir
zusteuerten und der seinen Kurs nicht
verändern werde also so hat er gesagt
müssten wir unseren Kurs ändern wenn es
nicht zu einer Kollision kommen soll
das war dann die Stelle an ihrer Rede
der
Bundesfinanzminister ihre eisbergrede
von der an Sie nur noch den Beifall ihre
eigenen Fraktion bekommen haben und in
deren weiteren Verlauf gleich drei
Bundesminister der Grünen Frau Berger
demonstrativ die Regierungsbank
verlassen haben
spätestens seit gestern
spätestens seit gestern haben wir also
zwei Oppositionsführer in Deutschland
einen im Parlament und einen in der
Regierung auf gute Zusammenarbeit
Christian Lindner
der Bundesfinanzminister hat in dieser
eisbergrede berechtigterweise auch
einige Fragen an uns gestellt wie wir
denn mit diesen Herausforderungen
umgehen würden lassen Sie mich darauf
einige wenige Antworten geben in der
Kürze der Zeit einige wenige aber schon
schon aus unserer Sicht jedenfalls
wichtige die ganz grundsätzliche Antwort
lautet zunächst die Zeitenwende kann
sich nicht in einer Schulden
finanzierten übergangsfinanzierung der
Bundeswehr erschöpfen das ist nicht die
Zeiten denn
sie hätten in ihrer Koalition
sie hätten in ihrer Koalition im letzten
Jahr den Koalitionsvertrag auf die Seite
legen müssen und die gesamten
Prioritäten vor allem der Aufgaben der
Aufgaben neu ordnen müssen stattdessen
versprechen sie der Bevölkerung es könne
während und nach dem Krieg alles so
weitergehen wie bisher teilweise erhöhen
sie sogar die konstruktiven Ausgaben
noch ohne die Folgen abzuschätzen und
einzuordnen ja das ist genau der Eisberg
den ihn Christian Lindner gestern hier
beschrieben hat und auf den wir
zusteuern das ist genau der Eisberg
meine Damen und Herren was
was müssten daraus für
Schlussfolgerungen gezogen werden
zunächst unser Land erstickt in
Bürokratie wir würden sofort alle
Gesetze stoppen wir würden sofort alle
Gesetze stoppen die diesen wahnsinnigen
Bürokratieaufwand immer noch weiter
erhöhen dazu zählen eben das
angekündigte kindergrundsicherungsgesetz
dass wir bis heute nicht haben und das
Gebäude Energiegesetz wir würden es
nicht machen so wie wir sie wie sie es
hier vorschlagen und in diesem in dieser
Woche hier noch durchsetzen wollen
das wollen das Gebäude Energiegesetz ist
übrigens ein gutes Stichwort wir würden
im Gebäudesektor wie im Verkehrssektor
auf echte
technologieoffenheit setzen es ist doch
keine Überraschung meine Damen und
Herren dass sie mit ihrer Verbotspolitik
auch im zweiten Jahr in Folge die
Klimaziele verfehlen ihre Klimapolitik
ihre Klimapolitik
wird von den Menschen im Land
mehrheitlich nicht mehr mitgetragen weil
die Menschen ist einfach leid sind nur
noch mit Verboten Regulierungen und
kalkulierbaren Kosten und bürokratischen
Auflagen konfrontiert zu werden wenn man
den Klimaschaden will dann muss man es
genau so machen wie sie es gegenwärtig
machen genau so
wir würden wir würden das sogenannte
Bürgergeld so ausgestalten dass sich
Arbeit mehr lohnt als der Bezug von
staatlichen Transferleistungen
ich verstehe dass sie hier sehr nervös
reagieren aber das ist doch die Wahrheit
die wir im Augenblick sehen die Menschen
gehen nicht zurück in die Beschäftigung
weil sie sich ausrechnen können dass sie
mit staatlichen Transferleistungen am
Ende des Jahres mehr herausbekommen als
wenn sie in einer einfachen
Beschäftigung arbeiten und
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge und Steuern
bezahlen müssen
wir würden den älteren Beschäftigten
meine Damen und Herren einen Anreiz
geben eben nicht in die Frühverrentung
zu gehen sondern dem Arbeitsmarkt länger
zur Verfügung zu stehen sie machen davon
genau das Gegenteil sie reden über
Fachkräfte Einwanderung und lassen es zu
dass 260 Menschen vorzeitig in den
Altersruhestand gehen nur damit das hier
klar ist weil ich das hier unter
Koalition höre das sind nicht die
Menschen die zu faul sind die Menschen
können einfach rechnen im Gegensatz zu
manchen von ihnen wie können rechnen
vier Tage Woche früh Verrentung
Bürgergeld meine Damen und Herren das
Problem sind nicht die Menschen die das
in Anspruch nehmen dies das Problem sind
sie die das ermöglichen und die die
politischen Rahmenbedingungen dafür
schaffen dass das so ist dass sich
Leistung nicht mehr lohnt
wir würden an den Grenzen zu Polen zur
Tschechischen Republik und auch zur
Schweiz ja nicht neue Schlagbäume
errichten aber wir würden die beständig
weiter ansteigende Zahl der illegalen
Grenzübertritte so kontrollieren wie
dies bereits so kontrollieren wie dies
bereits seit 2015 an der Grenze zu
Österreich stattfindet was ist
eigentlich der Unterschied zum
Grenzübertritt in Tschechien in
Österreich in der Schweiz oder aus Polen
was ist eigentlich der Unterschied
danke dass Sie hier sind heute morgen
Frau Feser vielleicht erläutern Sie uns
mal in den nächsten Tagen was eigentlich
der Unterschied ist nachdem sie sich
gestern krank gemeldet haben und in
Wiesbaden dpa Interviews gegeben haben
schön dass Sie hier sind und vielleicht
sagen Sie mal etwas zu diesem
Sachverhalt und zu diesem illegalen
grenzüberschritten
ja ich verstehe dass ihnen das
unangenehm ist aber sie haben ja einen
Koalitionspartner der bis zum heutigen
Tag beharrlich bestreitet dass es
überhaupt
illegale Migration gibt wenn Sie einen
solchen Koalitionspartner haben dann
kommen sie natürlich nicht zu einer
Lösung dieses Problems das aber
mittlerweile unsere Gesellschaft tief
spaltet und dass uns demnächst Brot um
die Ohren zu fliegen wenn sie es nicht
lösen meine Damen und Herren
und dann könnten wir und dann könnten
wir auch einmal über die Aufgaben und
Aufgaben Verteilung zwischen Bund und
Ländern und Gemeinden miteinander reden
aber erst bitte nachdem Sie dieses
Problem gelöst haben und dafür gesorgt
haben dass Länder und Gemeinden nicht
über Gebühren mit diesen Problemen
belastet werden ganz interessant der
Bundesfinanzminister hat ja erstmalig in
diesem Jahr einen Bericht anfertigen
lassen über die Leistungen des Bundes
zur Mitfinanzierung von Länder und
kommunalaufgaben herausgekommen im
August 2023 er kommt dabei auf einen
Betrag von 56 Milliarden Euro den der
Bund ausgibt für Aufgaben die eigentlich
länderaufgaben und kommunalaufgaben sind
wir haben in unserem Berechnungen nicht
ganz diesen Betrag erreicht wir liegen
bei ungefähr 40 Milliarden Euro aber
immerhin das ist doch eine Summe aus der
sich heraus das Potenzial ergibt die
eine Neuverteilung der Aufgaben zwischen
Bund und Ländern jetzt vorgenommen
werden müsste meine Damen und Herren und
wenn wir das dann täten wenn sie das
alles machen würden
dann hätten wir auch schnell Spielräume
die z.B für eine größere Steuerreform in
Deutschland gebraucht würden wir könnten
dann endlich den Soli abschaffen das
würde vor
allem Unternehmen in Deutschland schnell
und wirksam helfen
aber das wollen sie nicht weil sie
natürlich in ihrer ganzen Klassenkampf
Rhetorik immer nur von den Reichen und
den breiten Schultern sprechen die sie
meinen immer noch mehr belasten zu
müssen das Gegenteil wäre richtig gerade
auch im Interesse der kleinen und
mittleren Unternehmen die weitgehend
Personengesellschaften sind in
Deutschland wir könnten dann
so wie die FDP das ja wohl auch will wir
könnten dann für Personengesellschaften
und Kapitalgesellschaften in Deutschland
eine einheitliche Unternehmenssteuer
einführen die vor allem reinvestierte
Gewinne mit maximal 25% belastet das
wären international wettbewerbsfähige
Steuersätze und dann könnten wir sogar
in der in den Einkommensteuertarif in so
gestalten dass sich Leistung wirklich
wieder lohnt aber der
Einkommensteuertarif dann eben nur und
ausschließlich für die privaten
Einkünfte herangezogen wird das wäre mal
ein Steuerkonzept wo sich Leistung lohnt
und wo die Attraktivität des
investitionsstandorts und
arbeitsstandort Deutschland wirklich
schnell und nachhaltig gesteigert werden
könnte
und daher jetzt da er jetzt da ist da er
jetzt angekommen ist Herr Lindner im
Sinne einer guten Zusammenarbeit würde
ich sie gerne bitten nicht auf das
hereinzufallen was vom Generalsekretär
der SPD in den letzten Tagen dazu
veröffentlicht worden ist das hat mit
unseren steuerpolitischen Vorstellungen
nichts gar nichts zu tun das sind nicht
unsere steuerpolitischen Vorstellungen
sie sehen also meine Damen und Herren
wir diskutieren hier nicht nur über die
Details des Bundeshaushaltes wie wir der
sprechen ihnen in ihrem ganz
grundsätzlichen Staatsverständnis sie
bauen nämlich
trotz zeitenwände den betreuenden
bevormundenden alles regulierenden und
dann auch finanzierenden Staat einen
geradezu paternalistischen Staat immer
weiter aus der möglichst hohe Steuern
einnimmt um sie dann nach Abzug eines
immensen Verwaltungsapparates den sie
natürlich am liebsten aus ihren eigenen
Reihen besetzen mit ihm Menschen Kosten
aus diesem Apparat dann gönnerhaft an
die Bevölkerung nach ihren
parteipolitischen Vorstellungen wieder
einen Teil davon zurückzugeben das ist
der Staat den Sie gerne hätte
und es ich kann es ihnen nicht ersparen
der Bundeskanzler sie werden das nicht
so ganz gerne hören aber sie haben mal
als Generalsekretär der SPD von der
Lufthoheit über den Kinderbetten
gesprochen die die SPD erreichen müssen
sie sind auf diesem Weg ein ganzes Stück
vorangekommen und Kindergrundsicherung
ist genau das was Sie erreichen wollen
Luft über dieser Gesellschaft damit Sie
sie nach ihren eigenen Vorstellungen
gestalten können das ist das was sie
wollen
wir
ja ich kann ja verstehen dass sie das
alles nicht gerne hören aber meine Damen
und Herren es gibt eben einen wirklich
grundlegenden Unterschied zwischen Ihnen
und uns wir wollen wir wollen ja danke
für den Beifall bestätigt genau das was
ich jetzt sagen möchte wir wollen
nämlich den Menschen den Unternehmen und
vor allem den Ingenieurinnen und
Ingenieuren in unserem Land etwas
zutrauen wir wollen sie zur Leistung und
zur gemeinsamen Gestaltung unseres
Landes wirklich ermutigen und befähigen
sie tun von fast alledem genau das
Gegenteil sie tun genau das Gegenteil
und wenn die Menschen dann am Ende des
Monats auf ihre Lohn- und
Gehaltsabrechnung schauen und Sie sehen
welche Steuern und Abzüge sie dazu
bezahlen haben und gleichzeitig hören
was sie ohne Arbeit in diesem Land auch
bekommen könnten wenn sie dann
anschließend monatelang auf einen
Arzttermin warten und keine Kitaplätze
für die Kinder bekommen ja hat dann
entsteht eben genau diese Stimmung im
Land die wir heute haben Herr
Bundeskanzler beschweren sie sich nicht
über die Stimmung das ist genau die
Stimmung die sie mit ihrer Koalition in
Deutschland herbeiführen und daran
müssen sie grundlegend etwas ändern wenn
sich in diesem Land zum besseren etwas
wenden soll
das war Friedrich Merz der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Union mit
heftiger Kritik an der Regierung vor
allem an der Kindergrundsicherung am
Gebäude Energiegesetz an der Erhöhung
des Bürgergeldes und an den zu geringen
Verteidigungsetat von Klassenkampf
Rhetorik sprachenärztin er widerspreche
der Regierung in ihrem Staatsverständnis
zu viel Regulierung zu viel Personal das
war seine Kritik es wird nun folgen der
Bundeskanzler er ist ja am Wochenende
beim Joggen gestürzt hat sich im Gesicht
verletzt und trägt daher eine Augenbinde
und
für die Bundesregierung hat als nächster
Redner das Wort der Bundeskanzler oder
Scholz
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lieber Herr Merz
ich will ganz ausdrücklich sagen es
funktioniert nicht mit den popanzen in
dieser Republik
und der wichtigste Popanz den sie eben
aufgebaut haben
hat etwas zu tun mit der Aufkündigung
eines konsensystem wir hier mit zwei
Drittel Mehrheit sogar etwas mehr
gefasst haben als wir das Sondervermögen
für die Bundeswehr beschlossen haben
sie kündigen den gerade auf und sie
werden dem Ernst der Lage der mit der
zeitenwände die der russische
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine darstellt
überhaupt nicht gerecht mit ihrer nur
rhetorisch gemeinten will
das ist schlecht das ist schlecht weil
die Aufgabe auf die zeitenwände zu
reagieren die der russische
Angriffskrieg darstellt und die
Bedrohung die er für die
Sicherheitsarchitektur in Europa
darstellt und es ja nicht nur in dieser
sondern viele viele Legislaturperioden
beschäftigen wird und ja wir geben jetzt
die 100 Milliarden aus damit die
Bundeswehr ab dem nächsten Jahr zwei
Prozent NATO Quote am Finanzmitteln zur
Verfügung hat und ja schon jetzt
schon heute ist klar das allerspätestens
ab 2028 wird zusätzliche 25 vielleicht
auch fast 30 Milliarden Euro für die
Bundeswehr aus dem Bundeshaushalt direkt
finanzieren müssen und deshalb ist der
Ernst der Lage nicht Rhetorik und
Popanze sondern dass wir in allem was
wir jetzt tun dazu beitragen dass wir in
dem Jahr in der Lage sein werden diese
Haushaltsmittel auch aufzubringen wir
garantieren der Bundeswehr zwei Prozent
NATO Quote auch 28 29
[Applaus]
30er Jahren das soll jetzt so sein
und da
und daher März passt es nicht dazu dass
sie in dem was Sie gesagt haben darauf
verweisen dass sie hier in dieser Woche
Steuervorschläge gemacht haben die alle
noch irgendwie versucht werden zu
verstehen weil sie ja gar nicht so genau
sind aber bei denen man jedenfalls
errechnen kann dass die 20 vielleicht 30
Milliarden Euro kosten
einfach so und wie geht das zusammen
wenn wir wissen wir müssen jetzt schon
jedes Jahr diszipliniert sein damit wir
28 29 diese Mittel aufbringen können und
sie machen Vorschläge als gäbe es kein
Morgen das sollten wir nicht mehr tun
und ja ich will auch sagen
wir müssen uns um die Leistungsträger in
dieser Gesellschaft kümmern und auch mit
Ihnen bin ich der Meinung dass dazu
gerne auch Leute gehören die sehr viel
Geld verdienen ich möchte dass es in
diesem Land und erfolgreiche Unternehmen
gibt es Startups Leute die aus dem was
sie schaffen Millionäre werden eine gute
Sache aber Herr Merz
aber Herr Merz aber Herr Merz
sie haben einen merkwürdigen
Leistungsträger begriff ich glaube der
fängt erst ab 120.000 Euro im Jahr an
und Leute die arbeiten und jeden Tag
berufstätig sind und 40 Stunden 45
Stunden die Woche arbeiten zählen bei
ihnen nichts dazu
deshalb haben sie hier mal so schlankweg
vorgeschlagen dass Leute die viele
Jahrzehnte berufstätig waren nicht mehr
ein paar Jahre früher ohne Abschläge in
Rente gehen können übrigens ja zwei
Jahre vorher als alle anderen das finden
Sie eine Bedrohung für nichts
Zusammenleben in Deutschland das so
fleißige Leute diese Möglichkeit haben
was für ein Leistungsbegriff ist das bei
ihm
ohnehin im Herz ohne März finde ich
interessant dass du den Vorschlägen die
sie am wichtigsten bei den
Sozialreformen finden ist dass wir das
gesetzliche Renten Eintrittsalter
anheben sollen das kommt immer wieder
als Obsession bei Ihnen in allen
Vorschlägen vor ich sage das ist nicht
gerecht gegenüber den fleißigen
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern dieses Landes
das musste jetzt sein weil ihr Popanz so
groß war
aber trotzdem aber trotzdem will ich
ausdrücklich sagen dass das eigentlich
nicht die Situation für die ganz
klassischen Schlagabtausche in diesem
Bundestag auch bei dieser Debatte ist
wobei es eben frei steht der Krieg die
Energiekrise die Inflation die Folgen
der Klimakrise das alles sorgt für
gewaltige Veränderung Veränderungen die
vielen Bürgern und Bürgern Sorgen machen
die für uns für Verunsicherung sorgen
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger in einer
solchen Lage von uns erwarten ist doch
kein Schattenboxen hier im Bundestag sie
wollen Orientierung mutige Kompromisse
zur anzupackende Arbeit für unser Land
das ist der Anspruch an uns alle
an die Regierungsparteien die in den
letzten Monaten zu viel gestritten haben
und genauso an die demokratische
Opposition
so setzen wir denen etwas entgegen die
politischen Profit schlagen wollen aus
abstiegsszenarien und Panikmache die
allermeisten Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
wissen dass die selbst ernannte
Alternative in Wahrheit ein Abbruch
Kommando ist ein Abbruch Kommando für
unser Land
unser Wohlstand ist auch das Ängste
verknüpft mit der Europäischen Union und
selbst setzt deshalb sind die
Forderungen nach neuen Schlagzeugen
zwischen den Mitgliedstaaten nach einem
Rückbau der Europäischen Union und nach
einem radikalen Abbau des Sozialstation
nichts als mutwillige
wohlstandsvernichtung
umso mehr sind wir die demokratischen
Kräfte gefordert an wirklichen Lösung zu
arbeiten zu viel ist in den vergangenen
Jahren auf die lange Bank geschoben
worden der heute mit der Bahn oder mit
dem Auto von Hamburg nach München fährt
der lebt bei jeder weichenstörung unter
jeder Brückenbaustelle wie sehr unsere
Infrastruktur auf Verschleiß gefahren
wurde statt in die Zukunft zu
investieren haben wir über die PKW-Maut
diskutiert und die jahrelange
Vernachlässigung unser Bundeswehr bis
zur Zeit Wende ist hier schon so oft
debattiert worden dass sich darüber
nicht mehr als das zu Anfang sagen muss
es war eine
Koalition unter CDU-Führung die die
große Sparprogramme bei der Bundeswehr
gemacht haben dort never forget
vergessen Sie es nicht sie waren das
die Vorgängerregierung haben beschlossen
aus der Kernenergie auszusteigen und aus
der Kohleverstromung wohlgemerkt beides
finde ich richtig nur der aussteigt der
muss so um so dringender einsteigen
Einsteigen in die erneuerbaren Energien
genau das tun wir jetzt übrigens auch
dort wo der Nacht am größten ist im
Süden und Westen unseres Landes
erstmals seit Jahren ist unübersehbar
dass wir in Deutschland auf einen Mangel
an Arbeitskräften zu steuern
das sehen wir das ist etwas das seit
vielen Jahren uns umtreibt und deshalb
ist es ganz ganz wichtig dass wir alles
dafür tun dass wir diesen
Arbeitskräftemangel bekämpfen können und
ich finde es wichtig dass wir damit auch
jetzt gestartet sind mit den Maßnahmen
die wir mit dem Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz auf den Weg gebracht
haben aber genauso wie bei dem Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien genauso wie
bei den Maßnahmen die wir ergreifen
müssen damit wir es schaffen das
Fachkräfte in unserem Land da sind
genauso ist es überall wichtig dass wir
Tempo machen deshalb nochmal an dieser
Stelle wenn uns zum Beispiel ein großer
Versorger wie er und sagt er hat 600
Verfahren am laufen nur wenige davon
sind bisher abgewickelt worden für die
Ausbau der Verteilnetze dann ist das
etwas dass wir nicht mehr so lassen
können wie es heute ist das ist meine
feste Überzeugung
das geht so nicht weiter
[Musik]
immer wenn ich in den letzten Monaten in
Deutschland unterwegs bin höre ich die
Botschaft sorgt dafür dass wir unser
Land auf Vordermann bringen und dass wir
schneller werden unkomplizierter und
weniger bürokratisch so wie das zum
Beispiel mit dem deutschlandticket der
Fall gewesen ist dass den öffentlichen
Nahverkehr so viel attraktiver gemacht
hat
so wie mit dem deutschlandtempo indem
wir immer weniger Monate neue
flüssiggast Terminals ans Netz gebracht
haben solche Erfolge haben zwei
Voraussetzungen erstens moderne Gesetze
schnelle Verfahren weniger Bürokratie
und zweitens die Bereitschaft aller
wirklich alle an einem Strang zu ziehen
und natürlich auch in eine Richtung der
Bund die Länder Städte und Gemeinden
Unternehmen und Behörden Verbände und
Gewerkschaften nur gemeinsam werden wir
den Mehltau aus Bürokratismus
Risikoscheu und Verzagtheit abschütteln
der sich über Jahre Jahrzehnte hinweg
über unser Land gelegt hat
dieser Mehltau nimmt unser Wirtschaft
und er sorgt für Frust bei den Leuten im
Land die einfach wollen dass Deutschland
ordentlich funktioniert dass die Bahn
pünktlich fährt dass unsere
Infrastruktur analog und digital zu den
besten in Europa zählt das einem die
Ämter unter die Arme greifen und keine
Schwierigkeiten machen das erwarten die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger nach Jahren des
Stillstands
in meiner Verantwortung als
Bundeskanzler möchte ich Ihnen daher
heute ein Angebot machen mein Vorschlag
richtet sich an die 16 Regierungschefin
und Regierungschefin der Länder an die
Landrätinnen und Landräte an die
Bürgermeisterinnen und Bürgermeister
überall in unserer Republik und mein
Vorschlag richtet sich ausdrücklich auch
an Sie verehrter Herr Merz als
Vorsitzender der größten
Oppositionspartei die im Bundesrat in
den Ländern und Kommunen Verantwortung
trägt wir brauchen eine nationale
Kraftanstrengung lassen sie uns unsere
Kräfte bündeln
beweisen wir den Bürgern und Bürgern
wozu unser Land unser Föderalismus und
unsere Demokratie im standeset viele im
Lande warten gerade zu sehnsüchtig nach
einem solchen Schulterschluss und ich
möchte Ihnen Pakt vorschlagen sagen wir
einen deutschland-pakt ein Deutschland
packt der unser Land schneller moderner
und sicherer macht Tempo statt
Stillstand handeln statt aussetzen
Kooperation statt Streiterei
das ist das Gebot der Stunde
als Bundeskanzler kann ich natürlich
einen solchen Aufbruch nicht verordnen
für den Bund kann ich aber fest zusagen
wir gehen mit ganzer Kraft voran der
Deutschland packt setzt dort an wo die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger Fortschritte an
dringendsten erwarten bei der
Energieversorgung die sauber sicher und
bezahlbar sein muss beim Bauen neuer
Wohnung und Häuser bei der
Modernisierung und Digitalisierung
unserer Infrastruktur bei der
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unseren Unternehmen
bei einer schnellen leistungsfähigen und
digitalen Verwaltung
wir haben den 16 Ländern dazu sehr
konkrete Vorschläge gemacht und das mein
Gespräch mit Ländern und Kommunen weiß
ich sie teilen unser Ziel schneller
moderner und sicherer zu werden das gilt
übrigens für alle regierungschefinnen
und Regierungschefs der Länder egal
welcher Partei sie angehören schneller
das heißt dass wir die Deutschland
Geschwindigkeit zum Maßstab für alle
großen erneuerungsprojekte in unserem
Land machen zum Beispiel indem wir noch
die letzten Hürden beim Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien abräumen das ist
doch der schnellste Weg für nachhaltige
und nachhaltigste Weg für niedrige
Strompreise und als ich
vor einigen Monaten gesagt habe wir
brauchen vier bis fünf neue Windräder
und viele viele Fußballfelder
Photovoltaikanlagen am Tag da habe ich
in viele gefragt wie soll das gehen aber
wir sehen es geht wir haben schon 30
Fußballfelder sogar Anlagen pro Tag die
installiert werden und es geht sogar
noch viel mehr wenn wir uns anschauen
was zum Beispiel bei den
Windkraftanlagen passiert dort haben wir
im Juni 200 Genehmigung gehabt wenn das
alles in diesem Tempo auch gebaut wird
und wir das halten können sind die vier
bis fünf Windräder pro Tag auch
erreichbar das ist das was wir heute
wissen
und ich bin froh
ich bin froh dass in vielen Ländern
jetzt auch das Tempo zugenommen hat und
Schleswig-Holstein Niedersachsen und
auch in Nordrhein-Westfalen ist die Zahl
der Genehmigung deutlich gestiegen
teilweise um 60 Prozent und das MUSS
schule machen
etwa wenn wir in den nächsten Jahren die
Netze für Strom und Wasserstoff Aufbauen
der Ausbau der Netze wird Investitionen
von mehr als 100 Milliarden Euro
auslösen und tausende gute Arbeitsplätze
schaffen bis Ende des Jahres stehen die
Pläne für den Aufbau des Wasserstoff
kernnetzes was wir vor allem brauchen
sind natürlich überall Beschäftigte in
den Planungsbehörden in den Bauämtern
die schnell und zügig und unkompliziert
die Genehmigung erteilen vielleicht hat
es früher gereicht dass man für
irgendein Flugplatz und für ein anderes
vorhaben 15 oder 15 Jahre braucht aber
das ist vorbei wir müssen jetzt das
Tempo erreichen dass den
Herausforderungen unseres Landes
entspricht
dann haben wir auch die Möglichkeit dass
wir die große Transformation hinkriegen
die ja immerhin so groß ist wie die
industrielle Modernisierung Deutschlands
am Ende des 19 Jahrhunderts
das schneller heißt natürlich auch dass
wir die Planungsprozesse überall
digitalisieren Schluss mit zwei Meter
Aktenordnern für den Bau eines soldatas
oder eine Mobilfunkantenne schneller
heißt das Gutachten und Umweltdaten die
schon oft da sind nicht noch mal
vorgelegt werden schneller heißt dass
wir EU-Regeln zum Naturschutzrecht eins
zu eins umsetzen damit das auch überall
gleich funktioniert schneller heißt dass
alle 16 Länder bis Ende des Jahres
Bauanträge auch digital annehmen
schneller heißt das nicht noch weitere
Gutachter und sachverständigung für
Genehmigung gebraucht werden wenn ein
Handwerksmeister bestimmter und Gebäude
und Gebäude Teile geplant schneller
heißt das Raumordnungsrecht so zu ändern
dass überall im Land neue
Geothermieanlagen entstehen können
schneller heißt dass wir eine
Anlaufstelle schaffen für
Schwertransporte auf Autobahn damit die
Rotorblätter für Windräder und vieles
andere besser transportiert werden kann
schneller heißt auch manche Genehmigung
kriegt einfach mal zu verzichten damit
Glasfaserleitung für den Nutzern kommen
alles das heißt schneller und darum
geht's wir müssen das Bürokratie dichten
der Deutschland packt dabei ist genau
das Arbeit im Maschinenraum unseres
Staates das Drehen an Hunderten von
Reglern um dafür zu sorgen dass der
Tanker Deutschland auf Touren kommt
damit das gelingt
muss unser Staat natürlich jetzt überall
den Schritt in das Digitalzeitalter
machen Ziel des Deutschlands Praxis ist
eine moderne digitale und bürgernahe
Verwaltung vergangene Woche in Meseberg
haben wir Eckpunkte für ein Bürokratie
entlastungsgesetz beschlossen das
besonders kleine und mittlere Betriebe
von unnötigen papierkramen entlasten
sollen auch gegenüber Brüssel setzen wir
uns für weniger Bürokratie und
schnellere Entscheidungen ein zum
Beispiel in Beihilfeverfahren das wollen
wir auch gerne mit Frankreich
vorantreiben
seit der Bund und die Länder sich 2017
darauf verständigt haben ihre
wichtigsten Verwaltungsleistung zu
digitale digitalisieren hat der Bund 85%
seiner Leistung umgesetzt
Länder und Kommunen haben bisher ein
Viertel der zugesagten Leistung online
zugänglich gemacht und dabei reden wir
über sehr zentrale Regel fragen wie die
Beantragung von Personalausweisen die
Verlängerung des Führerscheins oder die
Ummeldung nach dem Umzug ich weiß in
mehr als 10.000 großen und kleinen
Städten und vielen Gemeinden mit ganz
unterschiedliche IT- und
Personalausstattung ist das alles nicht
trivia
aber es ist den Bürgern und Bürgern
schlicht nicht mehr zu erklären dass sie
zwar im Internet einkaufen
geldüberweisen und ihren Urlaub buchen
können aber dass solch grundlegende
Verwaltungsleistungen noch immer nicht
überall in Deutschland online möglich
sind das muss sich ändern
und ganz wichtig dieses Vorhaben
scheitert nicht am Geld in den
zurückliegenden vier Jahren hat der Bund
den Ländern und Kommunen dafür 1,4
Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung gestellt
hunderte Millionen können noch abgerufen
werden
auch über andere Großbaustellen werden
wir mit den Ländern im Rahmen des
Deutschlands packt reden wollen was
stauanfällige Straßen marode Brücken
angeht sorgen wir per Gesetz dafür dass
schneller geplant und gebaut wird das
muss jetzt auch passieren
und auch den Investitionsstau bei der
kaputt gesparten Bahn gehen wir an 24
Milliarden Euro an zusätzlichen
Investitionsspielraum erhält die Bahn in
den kommenden vier Jahren das ist das
größte Investitionsprogramm in so kurzer
Zeit ich sag mal seit der Dampflok ein
großer Fan
wer schon selber mal ein Haus gebaut hat
weiß da gibt es jetzt viele Baustellen
aber ich bin sicher die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger werden dafür Verständnis haben
weil sie sehen jetzt wird endlich
angepackt anstatt unsere Infrastruktur
weiter verfallen zu lassen
eine der zentralen Botschaften des
Deutschlands Paktes ist daher auch wir
denken über den Tag hinaus wir legen
heute den Grundstein für Wohlstand und
die Stabilität in unserem Land in den
nächsten 10 20 und 30 Jahren
und ich sage das gerade auch in Richtung
derjenigen die jetzt immer irgendwie
über die Industrialisierung unseres
Landes sprechen die große
Leistungsfähigkeit unser Industrie habe
ich gestern gerade bei der IAA mobility
der Internationalen Automobilausstellung
sehen können das ist kein Land dem die
die Industrialisierung übervorsteht das
weltweit wettbewerbsfähig ist mit seiner
leistungsfähigen Industrie
ja
niemand kann zu frieden sein wenn
Deutschlands Wirtschaft nicht wächst
doch wir werden strukturelle Probleme
nur mit strukturellen Antworten lösen
das beste Wachstumsprogramm ist wenn ein
Betrieb statt drei Jahre künftig
vielleicht nur drei Monate auf eine
Baugenehmigung oder die
Betriebserlaubnis wartet zumal solche
strukturellen Verbesserung auch
günstiger und nachhaltiger sind als
dauer-subvention ich halte auch nichts
ich halte auch nichts von Schulden
finanzierten Strohfeuer namens
Konjunkturprogramm dass die
Inflationsbekämpfung die so wichtig ist
seitens der Europäischen Zentralbank
konterkarieren würde wir sorgen
stattdessen dafür dass unsere
Unternehmen jetzt in die Zukunft
investieren können die Beschlüsse die
wir vergangene Woche in Meseberg
getroffen haben senden eine klare
Botschaft wer jetzt in saubere Energie
und Klimaschutz investiert der spart
dank der investitionsprämie viel Geld
mit der Ausweitung des Verlustvortrags
sorgen wir mit einem Schlag für mehr
Liquidität in Unternehmen rückwirkend ab
dem 1 oktober werden neue großzügige
abschreibungsregeln für alle beweglichen
Wirtschaftsgüter möglich damit auch
kleine und mittlere Unternehmen
investieren können und die großen auch
und Betriebe den Geld-
investieren können künftig mehr von der
Steuer absetzen und natürlich das
wichtige großzügige abschreibungsregeln
werden auch den Bau neuer Häuser und
Wohnungen unterstützen das sorgt für
mehr Investitionen in der Bauwirtschaft
denn wir wollen das Ziel nicht aufgeben
mehr Wohnungen in diesem Land zu bauen
ja die Zinserhöhung haben zu einer
anpassungskrise geführt die steigenden
Baupreise auch die zu hohen
Grundstückspreise übrigens auch aber was
ganz wichtig ist dass wir darüber nicht
aufhören zu verstehen dass jetzt in
großer Zahl bezahlbare Wohnung für
Millionen Menschen in diesem Land gebaut
werden müssen und deshalb werden wir
alles tun damit wir so weit kommen dass
wir tatsächlich jedes Jahr und Jahr für
Jahr 400.000 Wohnungen errichten kann
wir werden das auf einem Baugefühl
besprechen aber ich sage ausdrücklich
vielleicht war da die eine oder andere
Wohnung bei der man sehr viel Geld
zahlen muss um da einziehen zu können zu
viel geplant und zu wenige Wohnungen
geplant bei die sich jemand leisten kann
der auch zu einem Leistungsträger geht
hört weil er 40 Stunden die Woche
arbeite aber nicht so viel verdient
18 Milliarden Euro stecken wir in den
geförderten Wohnungsbau damit das auch
funktioniert
und natürlich dürfen wir nicht vergessen
unser wichtigstes Instrument den Klima
und transformationsfonds allein in
kommenden Jahr sind darin 58 Milliarden
Euro Investitionen möglich in
Wasserstoffwirtschaft in die
Halbleiterindustrie in saubere Energie
klimafreundliche Mobilität digitale
Infrastruktur und die Sanierung von
Gebäuden
rekordinvestitionen aus dem
Bundeshaushalt kommen noch dazu 54
Milliarden für bessere Schienen und
Brücken schnelles Internet oder
Ladesäulen alles das zusammen sind 110
Milliarden Euro mit denen wir in der
Lage sind trotz der Tatsache dass wir
jetzt in den Ausgaben die wir tätigen
müssen vorsichtig umgehen müssen mit
denen wir Investitionen in unserem Land
tätigen können und die Schuldenregel der
Verfassung einhalten
wir sehen übrigens auch erste Erfolge
mehr als 80 Milliarden Euro investieren
internationale Unternehmen in den
Standort Deutschland und zwar in
Zukunftsbranchen die Biotechnologie und
batteriefertigung cleantec
klimaneutralen Stahl und künstliche
Intelligenz und wir sind gerade dabei zu
dem Halbleiter Standort in Europa zu
werden die 30 Milliarden Euro
Investitionen von Intel in Magdeburg ist
die größte ausländische
Einzelinvestition in der Geschichte
Europas hinzu kommen hinzu kommen die
neuen Fabriken von Infineon in Sachsen
von Wulf Speed und ZF im Saarland die
Investitionen von Global foundrys in
Dresden und zuletzt der Einstieg von
TSMC in die Chip-Produktion auch in
Dresden übrigens im Verbund mit NXP
Infineon und Bosch denn es ist ja nicht
so dass wir in dieser Frage
technologisch erst alles lernen müssen
jede dieser Investitionen stärkt unsere
technologische Souveränität und jede
dieser Investitionen sorgt dafür dass
Dutzende Zulieferer für gute und sichere
Arbeitsplätze und für auf davon
profitieren und für Aufträge beim
lokalen Handwerk ganze Städte und
Regionen profitieren davon auf Dauer und
deshalb werden wir als Bund diesen
großen Fortschritt der mit der
Wiederansiedlung der Halbleiterindustrie
in Europa und zwar in Deutschland
verbunden ist auch weiter unterstützen
übrigens tun das andere Länder auch um
das mal im Hinblick auf eine etwas
merkwürdige Debatte hierzulande zu sagen
wenn man die Unternehmen fragt was der
größte Unsicherheitsfaktor für Sie ist
dann sind das nicht so sehr die
Energiepreise oder die Frage ob sie noch
mehr Subventionen bekommen können
sondern dann ist das der Mangel an
Arbeitskräften das ist in der Tat die
große Herausforderung für unser Land und
deshalb tun wir erstmal alles dafür dass
diejenigen die hierzulande aufwachsen
auch die besten Bedingungen vorfinden
und dass wir alles dafür tun können dass
sie einen guten Arbeitsplatz und eine
gute Ausbildung bekommen und wir haben
auch damit das geklappt Mittel
bereitgestellt damit die Länder und
Gemeinden Kitas ausbauen können vier
Milliarden Euro wer allerdings behauptet
wir können völlig ohne Arbeitskräfte aus
dem Ausland am auskommen der hat in den
letzten Jahren nicht mehr mit
Handwerksmeister mittelständlerinnen und
krankenhausbetreibern
13 Millionen Beschäftigte gehen bis
Mitte kommenden Jahrzehnts in den
Ruhestand deshalb ist es notwendig dass
wir das auch tun und ich appellieren
alle dass das jetzt schon beschlossene
fachkräfteeinwanderungsgesetz jetzt
überall in Deutschland umgesetzt wird
damit wir unbürokratisch die
Möglichkeiten haben und der
Krankenpfleger aus Georgien und die
IT-Spezialisten aus Indien nicht Monate
auf ein Visum oder eine Arbeitserlaubnis
warten müssen
moderne untereinander vernetzte
Ausländerbehörden nutzen übrigens auch
an anderer Stelle wer hier kein
Aufenthaltsrecht hat der muss unser Land
natürlich wieder verlassen in Meseberg
haben wir beschlossen Georgien und
molder aus sicherer Herkunftsländer
einzustufen das ist ein wichtiger
Fortschritt im Kampf gegen die
irreguläre Migration
und ich bin der bundesinnenministerin
sehr dankbar dafür dass sie den Ländern
auch in Sachen Rückführung bei der
Ausweitung der Abschiebehaft und an
vielen anderen Stellen ganz konkrete
Verbesserungsvorschläge gemacht hat
schönen Dank für diese Arbeit
auch das muss Teil des Deutschlands
praktisch sein und mir ist schon
aufgefallen was passiert
die Bundesregierung hat alles was zu tun
ist auf den Weg gebracht über die
sicheren Herkunftsländer habe ich eben
gesprochen über Verbesserung aller seit
Jahren nicht zustande gekommene Regelung
bei der rechtlichen Organisation der
Abschiebung habe ich auch gesprochen
über die europäische Verständigung über
ein solidaritätsmechanismus damit nicht
alle zu uns kommen sondern dass ein
gemeinsames Verfahren wird habe ich
haben wir hier schon diskutiert wir
haben darüber diskutiert wie die
Digitalisierung der Ausländerbehörden
vorangeht und und und
aber dann wenn das alles passiert dann
suchen sie sich immer noch das nächste
Thema so viel wie hier auf der Agenda
steht haben CDU Innenminister in den
letzten Jahren nicht vorangebracht
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen nach drei
außergewöhnlichen Krisenjahren steht der
Bundeshaushalt 2024 für die Rückkehr zur
Normalität und für einen solide
finanzierten Staat wir investieren ohne
an der falschen Stelle zu kürzen weil
wir wissen
gesellschaftlicher Zusammenhalt ist die
entscheidende Voraussetzung dafür dass
alle mitkommen können auf dem Weg in die
Zukunft unseres Landes durch den
Ausgleich der kalten Progressionen haben
48 Millionen Steuerzahlerinnen und
Steuerzahler mehr Netto vom Brutto wir
reden hier über den größten steuerlichen
Inflationsausgleich die in eine
Bundesregierung jemals vorgenommen hat
danke für den Applaus aus der CDU
die Tarifpartner machen millionenfach
Gebrauch von unserem Vorschlag den
Beschäftigten mit Steuer und
abgabenfreien Einmalzahlung durch die
Inflation zu helfen und das alles zeigt
wirkt Wirkung erstmals seit zwei Jahren
steigt die Kaufkraft in Deutschland
wieder am deutlichsten sind die Löhne
übrigens bei denjenigen gestiegen die am
wenigsten verdienen und darauf bin ich
ganz besonders stolz
das ist auch ein Erfolg des Mindestwert
und der beschlossenen Reduzierung von
Steuern und Sozialabgaben für
Geringverdiener auch die Renten sind zum
ersten Juli so stark angehoben worden
wie seit Jahrzehnten nicht mehr als 30
Jahre nach der Wiedervereinigung ist
endlich die rentenangleichung zwischen
Ost und West geschafft
und auch die Familien hat diese
Bundesregierung massiv unterstützt
allein das höhere Kindergeld bedeutet
für eine Familie mit zwei Kindern über
700 € mehr im Jahr beim Kinderzuschlag
sind es bis zu 500 €. das alles fließt
ein in die neue Kindergrundsicherung die
im Jahr 25 eingeführt wird
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger Krieg
Klimawandel Energiekrise Inflation die
Folgen der Pandemie niemand hat sich die
Lage ausgesucht mit der wir es derzeit
zu tun haben aber gerade wenn man
bedenkt wie groß diese Herausforderung
sind wird doch ganz besonders deutlich
was wir hinbekommen wenn wir
zusammenhalten wir haben die Pandemie
überstanden mit weniger Opfern als viele
andere Staaten wir haben entschlossen
auf Russlands Angriffskrieg und seine
dramatischen Folgen reagiert ohne dass
die NATO Kriegspartei geworden ist nach
den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika sind
wir der zweitgrößte Unterstützer der
Ukraine
wir haben unser Land immer weniger
Monate aus der Abhängigkeit von
russischer Energie befreit ohne
Versorgungsengpässe ohne Blackouts ohne
Wut Winter ja ohne gutwinne und wir
kommen voran bei der Aufgabe unseres
Landes der Aufgabe unser Land so
aufzustellen dass unsere besten Tage
nicht hinter uns liegen sondern vor uns
auch das kriegen wir hin wenn wir
zusammenhalten und genau das erwarten
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger davon von uns
dass wir unsere Kraft zusammen nehmen
und gemeinsam anpacken dieses Angebot
mache ich Ihnen heute mit dem
deutschland-
das war die Rede des Bundeskanzlers kein
Schattenboxen sondern zupacken
verspricht Scholz ermahnt dabei auch die
eigene Koalition weniger zu streiten er
bietet der Opposition den Ländern und
Kommunen ein deutschland-pakt an für
mehr Tempo in allen Bereichen um den
Stillstand zu überwinden bei der Bahn
der Infrastruktur beim Bürokratieabbau
beim Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien um
nur wenige Beispiele zu nennen handeln
statt Streit das sei das Gebot der
Stunde
nächster Redner wird nun Timo krupala
sein der Fraktionsvorsitzende der AFD
der Partei die der Kanzler gerade als
abrufkommando bezeichnete
und für die afd-fraktion hat das Wort
Tino brutaler
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Landsleute Herr Bundeskanzler sie
sprachen in ihrer Rede von der
Deutschland Geschwindigkeit von der
Geschwindigkeit seit Erfindung der
Dampflokomotive welche Geschwindigkeit
das ist das Sehen aktuell die Bürger an
ihrer Wahrnehmung ihre Wahrnehmung zur
Situation des Landes geht wirklich an
den Problemen vorbei Herr Merz in ihrer
Rede muss man wirklich sagen sie suchen
jetzt nach dem grünen nach den nächsten
Koalitionspartner soll dann die FDP sein
dieser Schmusekurs eine FDP die in
dieser Bundesregierung Handwerk und
Mittelstand verrät diese FDP wird es
bald nicht mehr geben sie ist
überflüssig und das werden die nächsten
Landtagswahlen ganz deutlich zeigen was
wir heute und auch gestern schon von
Herr Linder gehört haben ist dass diese
ampelpolitik Schuldenpolitik bedeutet
und die Schulden werden eben nicht hier
in Berlin getilgt sondern draußen im
Land von den Bürgern und appelpolitik
ist auch immer ein Stück postmodern und
eben beliebig so sind die Berechnung der
Neuverschuldung doch recht kreativ auch
heute haben wir das von ihnen gehört
Herr
Bundeskanzler der Bundesfinanzminister
verpackte seinen Kunst war gestern in
sage und Schreiben 50 Minuten Rede wert
er Redezeit der Deutsche Bundestag ist
es nun dein Haushaltsentwurf
verabschieden soll indem die über 70
Milliarden Euro in den sogenannten
Sondervermögen also neue Schulden
versteckt sind und die zugewiesenen EU
Schulden von 13,2 Milliarden die hat er
ganz beflüssig unter den Tisch fallen
lassen und das zusätzlich zur
offiziellen Neuverschuldung von 16
Milliarden Euro also weit über 100
Milliarden Euro neue Schulden das zu
soliden Finanzen herr Scholz das ist
alles andere als dies
Zitat das Geld fällt doch nicht vom
Himmel ein Zitat von BDI-Präsident
Russwurm der Welt am Sonntag Zusagen der
vielleicht hat Herr Linda deshalb sogar
plötzlich die Schuldenbremse wieder für
sich und seine Politik entdeckt zu spät
meine Damen und Herren von der FDP 2
Jahre zu spät in dieser destruktiven
andere Regierung hätten sie noch den
meisten wirtschaftlichen Verstand
vielleicht besitzen müssen allerdings
hat das trojanische Pferd in der
Bundesregierung offenbar die Namen Freie
Demokraten in ihm verstecken sich
nämlich die Steigbügelhalter eines
dominanten Staates und sie erlinder
haben es im Bundeskabinett zugelassen
das mitten in der größten Inflation der
letzten Jahre deutsche Firmen ins
Ausland verkauft werden und aus ihrer
Fraktion kamen immer wieder die
kriegsliste an den Töne von Frau
Zimmermann die nun ihr Zug fährt für die
anstehenden Wahlen zum Europäischen
Parlament sein soll viel Spaß dazu
sie sind als Politiker und Partei
mittlerweile nur noch unglaubwürdig und
wirklich absolut überflüssig die FDP ist
im genau das was Sie schon immer war der
ping pong ball den die
Regierungsparteien für Koalitionen
brauchen und Werte Kollegen viele von
ihnen verbringen seit Monaten dann auch
in der Sommerpause Zeit damit den
Bürgern und den Medien zu erklären warum
die Alternative für Deutschland nicht
gut für unser Land sein soll nur
vergessen genau diese Leute auch dass
nicht wir in der Regierung sind dort
sitzen SPD Grüne und FDP und die CDU
findet sich noch immer in der Opposition
nicht ganz so recht mauert an seinen
brandneuerchen rum und auch das fällt
als Opposition komplett mittlerweile die
CDU aus alle diese Parteien
alle diese Parteien meine Damen und
Herren machen seit über 20
Legislaturperioden im Deutschen
Bundestag Politik sie sollen endlich mal
selbst und ihre politischen Leistung
anfangen zu kritisieren und sich
vielleicht einfach mal fragen warum gibt
es eigentlich eine Alternative für
Deutschland sie sollten endlich die Zoll
klappen auch absetzen und nicht alle
Anträge der afd-fraktion ablehnen denn
dann ging es unserem Land wirklich
besser meine Damen und Herren
in der Bevölkerung machen sie sich alle
anscheinend mehr und mehr unglaubwürdig
und das Entdecken offensichtlich immer
mehr Bürger von denen wollen sie zwar
alle wieder gewählt werden pro esken in
Sachsen sechs Prozent die SPD sie
sollten ganz leise sein aber deren
Interessen vertreten wollen sie schon
lange nicht mehr
Zitat die Lage wird toxisch sagt die
Präsidentin des VDA Hildegard Müller
Antworten der Politik jedoch die die
Interessen der Wirtschaft vertreten
sollten zum Beispiel wie unsere
Forderung CO2-Abgabe abschaffen
Energiesteuern runter die gibt es nicht
Bürokratieabbau ja dann lassen sie
endlich das liefergesetz kettengesetz
Fallen das braucht hier in diesem Land
niemand es geht mittlerweile auch
niemand mehr davon aus und ich im
Übrigen noch nie dass die Grünen mit
Steuergeld überhaupt umgehen können das
hat schon immer Spaß gemacht bei den
Grünen
das hat schon immer Spaß gemacht bei dem
Geld anderer Leute Gassi zu tragen und
wir werden von der Politik deshalb habe
ich tagtäglich darin auch bestätigt eine
solche wirtschaftsfeindliche Politik hat
es in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
noch nie gegeben meine Damen und Herren
diese grüne Wirtschaftspolitik
funktioniert nur in der gleichfarbigen
Blase einer Partei die daran glaubt dass
Klima retten zu können und das hat einen
Preis der für uns alle unbezahlbar wird
meine Damen und Herren allein das
heizungsgesetz GEG kostet unfassbare
2500 Milliarden Euro den Bürgern und das
sind ihre eigenen Zahlen aus der
Bundesregierung dieses Gesetz braucht
kein Mensch und
die Union soll nicht zu tun in Sachsen
plakatiert sie heizungsverbot stoppen
als wenn Sie dieses Gesetz auch nicht
wollte Frau von der Leyen wahrscheinlich
ihre Spitzenkandidatin von der CDU für
die europawahlplan sogar ein noch
schärferes Gesetz auf EU-Ebene diese
Doppelmoral ist sowas von unglaubwürdig
und das erkennen immer mehr Bürger
Zitat die die Industrialisierung
beginnt da stellt der
Vorstandsvorsitzende des
chemie-konzernses Matthias sachert fest
das sind sie und ihre Kabinett den es
realisieren wollen
trockeneisieren meine Kollegen und ich
ihn nachhaltig schon seit Monaten Herr
Bundeskanzler und deshalb öffnen sie
wieder wenn sie können bitte beide Augen
und sehen Sie wie die deutsche
Wirtschaft reagiert wie sie abschmiert
und kümmern Sie sich endlich um das
Rückgrat in diesem Land um die deutsche
Wirtschaft
laut dem Energiewende Barometer der DIHK
aber erwägen aktuell
43,3% aller Industrieunternehmen mit
über 300 Beschäftigten eine Verlegung
ihrer Kapazitäten ins Ausland 6,7%
planen dies bereits bei 17 Prozent
laufen diese Planungen und bei 19,7%
sind die Realisierungen schon
abgeschlossen damit packen aktuell
36,7% der größten Industriebetriebe ihre
Koffer und das war erst dann für den
Industriestandort das Ende in diesem
Land das ist die Realität der sie sich
komplett verschließen und diese
Bundesregierung hinterlässt eine
traurige Landschaft aus nicht
funktionierenden hoch subventionierten
Windrädern eine unsichere
Energieversorgung ohne Grundlast und
eine unendlich hohe Abgabenlast damit
schaffen sie keine Anreize für
wirtschaftliche Unternehmungen oder gute
Lebensbedingungen für all die Menschen
die tagtäglich zur Wertschöpfung
beitragen welches Geschlecht im
Personalausweis steht das können die
Bürger entscheiden
ob sie aber in Zukunft noch die heiz-
und Stromkosten bezahlen können oder
welche Heizung sie überhaupt einbauen
dürfen das wissen sie nicht werden die
Bundesregierung ihre politischen
Schwerpunkte sind völlig entrückt und
wie die Fazit sie sind absolut
regierungsunfähig
[Applaus]
und ich gebe Ihnen mal ein Beispiel aus
der Industrie eine Gießerei in meinen
Wahlkreis hat im Jahr 2016 für eine
Kilowattstunde Strom 11,47 Cent gezahlt
der Krieg in der Ukraine und die damit
erlassenen unsäglichen Sanktionen
führten zu einem Preisanstieg um 98% auf
22,37 Kilowattstunde im Jahr 2022 ab
März diesen Jahres muss dieser Betrieb
die nächste Erhöhung um 98% hinnehmen es
sind dann 44,99 die Kilowattstunde
dieser Betrieb habe ich hat eine super
CO2 Bilanz er produziert einfach nicht
mehr wie auch der Waggon Niesky der
Konkurs angemeldet hat das sind ja bis
180 Arbeitsplätze und nun erwartet
wirklich niemand dass der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister weiß was
darauf folgt ich kann es ihnen sagen
eine Schockstarre aus Kurzarbeit und
Hoffnung darauf dass der Staat seine
Grundaufgaben erfüllt und endlich
Infrastrukturpolitik macht das ist ihre
Aufgabe in diesem Land
mit ihnen und ihre Ampel der
Bundeskanzler hat Deutschland wirklich
fertig sie verspielen auch das sage ich
seit Monaten nicht nur das Vertrauen in
ihre Regierung sondern in die Politik
sie können uns daher dankbar sein dass
wir als einzig wahrnehmbare auch für die
Opposition Fehler hier in diesem Haus
klar benennen und deshalb die Bürger
überhaupt noch an die Wahl kommen und
das obwohl sie von ihrem Bundeskanzler
nicht einmal mehr ehrliche Worte
erwarten dürfen sie haben ihre Klausur
in Meseberg angesprochen und dort sagten
sie da der Presse die Preise sinken
über welche Preise sprachen sie da
eigentlich
die Teuerung spielt bei einer Inflation
von über 6 % wirklich jeder und die
nächsten Preissteigerungen sind bereits
angekündigt im Gastronomie in der
Automobilindustrie und bei den
energieergern hier ein Beispiel kostet
da eine klimawandstunde Gas für einen
Privathaushalt in diesem Sommer noch
aktuell 5,318 wird dieser Haushalt ab 1
Oktober diesen Jahres 9,7 Cent die
Kilowattstunde zahlen das ist eine
Preiserhöhung von
81%. aktuell und nebenbei gefragt herr
Scholz wissen sie inzwischen was ein
Liter Benzin oder diese kostet
mittlerweile sind wir wieder bei der 2
vor dem Komma ihre Wahrnehmung ist
mittlerweile vollkommen abgekoppelt von
der Lebenswirklichkeit sie leben in
einer Scheinwelt das hat Züge von den
letzten Tagen der Volkskammer in der DDR
aber sie haben immer neue Vorschläge wie
Sie mehr aus der Wirtschaft pressen
wollen um die Wirren klimawendepläne zu
erfüllen seien Sie deshalb auch mal
mutig und informieren Sie die Bürger
doch schon heute das mit der Verdopplung
der Mautgebühren auf deutschen
Autobahnen die ab 2024 kommen soll
wieder neue Preissteigerungen zu
erwarten sind und wieder wird die
Inflation dadurch hochgezogen im übrigen
ab 3,5 Tonnen das betrifft dann auch
Kleinunternehmer und den Mittelstand die
wieder darunter leiden werden es wird
wirklich Zeit dass die Bürger zu ihrem
Recht kommen und dafür garantiert der
Sozialstaat der auf einen Ausgleich
zwischen Arm und Reich zwischen Alt und
Jung zielt dieser Interessenausgleich
ist bei ihnen aber mittlerweile
vollkommen aus dem Blick geraten wenn
ich arbeiten möchte bekommt
Ersatzleistung nahezu bedingungslos und
die die Arbeiten verlieren Monat für
Monat am netto wie die Rentner liebe
Kollegen noch steigt die Lebenserwartung
in Deutschland damit auch der Bedarf ein
finanziell und medizinisch aber unter
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach wurden
Kliniken geschlossen und das schäbige
daran ist noch dass die impfgeschädigten
in diesem Land allein gelassen werden
steht die im Grundgesetz
garantierte
unantastbare Würde des Menschen bei
ihnen überhaupt noch im Mittelpunkt für
die eigene für die deutsche Bevölkerung
ihre fahrlässige und verfehlte
Migrationspolitik ist ein weiterer
Bereich mit dem diese Bundesregierung
unser Land spaltet mit dem diese
Bundesregierung wirklich auf Amokfahrt
weiter fährt der Strafrecht gewordene
Asylbewerber und Migranten konsequent
ausgewiesen werden müssen wäre wirklich
eine erste kleine Maßnahme aber nichts
passiert merken sie nicht wie sie hier
mittlerweile die Kontrolle darüber
verlieren wer in unser Land kommt
hunderte Migranten täglich an der
deutsch-polnischen Grenze diese
Geisterfahrt muss wirklich beendet
werden merken sie nicht wie die Bürger
als leid sind wie mit ihren
Steuergeldern umgegangen werden wird
der vorgelegte Entwurf zum
Bundeshaushalt beweist dass umso mehr
eine wirkliche Veränderung für unsere
Bürger die deutsche Wirtschaften ein
severines Deutschland in Europa kann es
nur mit Neuwahlen gehen Herr
Bundeskanzler machen Sie deshalb den Weg
frei die Zeit der Ampel ist abgelaufen
und es geht hier nicht um Parteipolitik
es geht hier sehr wohl um nationale
Kraftanstrengung und die wird es nur mit
der AFD geben es geht um unsere Heimat
in der wir unsere Kinder und Enkelkinder
sehr gern in Sicherheit und Wohlstand
leben möchten daran würden wir als
Alternative für Deutschland in einer
neuen Bundesregierung mit aller Kraft
mit Überzeugung und Glaubwürdigkeit im
Interesse Deutschlands und seiner Bürger
arbeiten vielen Dank
das war Tino krupala der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der AFD mit
heftigen Attacken auf alle Parteien
ampelpolitik sei Schuldenpolitik die FDP
nur ein Ping pong-weise die jeweiligen
Koalitionen grün und SPD wurden keine
Probleme lösen die Ampel sei absolut
regierungsunfähig es folgt die
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Grünen
Katharina drücke
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich möchte über
Deutschland sprechen über das was
Deutschland ist
sie Herr märz haben das vor wenigen
Tagen auf dem bayerischen Jahrmarkt
gillamos in einem Bierzelt getan sie
haben gesagt nicht Kreuzberg ist
Deutschland
gillamos ist Deutschland
Herr Merz dass sie dieses Bild gewählt
haben das ist kein Zufall das war nicht
im Rausch eines feucht fröhlichen
bierzeltrednertums solche Bilder wählen
Sie immer wieder solche Bilder werden
sie immer wieder um zu definieren wer
dazu gehört und wer nicht wer richtig in
diesem Land ist und wer falsch wenn sie
von kleinen Jungs im Kindergarten
sprechen deren Eltern muslimisch sind
dann sind das auf einmal nicht mehr
Kinder dann sind das kleine Paschas wenn
sie von ukrainischen geflüchteten
sprechen dann sind das auf einmal sozial
Touristen und wenn sie von Arbeitslosen
sprechen dann sind das auf einmal
Arbeitsverweigerer und auf der anderen
Seite da stehen die Leistungsträger oder
die normalen Menschen wie der Kollege
Hase in der Bundestagsdebatte gestern
gesagt hat
wenn wir zurückkommen auf das Bild mit
Kreuzberg dann frage ich Sie was an
Berlin Kreuzberg ist nicht deutsch und
was macht die Menschen im bayerischen
Bierzelt Deutscher ist das weil in
Kreuzberg Menschen vieler Nationen leben
und Menschen vieler Biografien und nicht
nur Menschen deren Familien seit
hunderten von Jahren in diesem Land
leben ist das weil in Kreuzberg Menschen
verschiedener Religionen leben und nicht
nur Menschen einer ist das weil in
Kreuzberg Menschen verschiedener
politischer Überzeugungen Leben und
Menschen verschiedener sexuelle
sexueller Identitäten und nicht nur
einer eine CDU die diesen Weg geht die
anfängt zu definieren wer normal ist und
wer nicht wer Deutsch ist und wer nicht
wer dazu gehört und wer nicht die geht
einen gefährlichen Weg wie geht ein
verantwortungslosen Weg gerade in einer
Zeit wie dieser
dass wir stattdessen bräuchten wäre eine
Volkspartei die den Anspruch Volkspartei
das heißt für alle eine Partei zu seinen
ernst nimmt was wir bräuchten wäre eine
konservative Partei die den Zusammenhalt
der Menschen in diesem Land nach vorne
stellt und zum Glück haben die Menschen
in diesem Land in zwei Krisen uns
gezeigt von Flensburg bis nach
Niederbayern dass sie diesen
Zusammenhalt schaffen warum sind wir
letztes Jahr besser durch eine Krise
gekommen als wir alle erwartet hätten
das lag daran weil dieses Land
zusammengehalten hat das lag daran bei
Menschen Gas gespart haben weil
Unternehmen Produktionslinien angestellt
haben eine gemeinsam daran geglaubt
haben dass wir diese Herausforderung
meistern können und wir haben das
geschafft die Gasspeicher sind besser
gefüllt als erwartet die Wirtschaft ist
besser durch die Krise gekommen als
viele Experten angekommen haben die LMG
Terminals werden schneller gebaut als
sie uns jemand Unkraut hätten die Preise
die sind deutlicher gesunken als wir
alle erwartet hätten das ist eine
gemeinsame Leistung die dieses Land
geschafft hat
und ja es gibt weiterhin große
Herausforderungen auch
wirtschaftspolitische und deswegen frage
ich mich warum gerade der Vorsitzende
der CDU Deutschlands in dieser
Generaldebatte kein einziges Wort zu
Wirtschaftspolitik verloren hat
betrachten sie das nicht mehr als ihre
Aufgabe hierfür Lösungsvorschläge zu
machen
als Ampel gegen die Aufgaben die vor uns
liegen an mit Tatkraft und mit Mut zur
Zukunft und mit Vertrauen in die Stärke
der Unternehmen in unserem Land das
größte Problem dass die Wirtschaft hat
ist eines über das sie noch nicht mal
sprechen das ist das Thema Arbeits- und
Fachkräftemangel denn wenn der Bäckerei
niemanden mehr finden der die Brötchen
verkauft wenn in der Lausitz die
Ingenieure fehlen und wenn in der Küste
in den Hotels die Arbeitskräfte ausgehen
dann können wir den Laden wir dicht
machen und sie reden noch nicht mal über
dieses Problem während wir als
Koalitionsfraktionen handeln
wir gehen die strukturellen Themen an
mit einem
fachkräfteeinwanderungsgesetz das seinen
Namen verdient hat mit einem modernen
Einwanderungsgesetz und mit der Reform
des Staatsangehörigkeitsrechts wir gehen
alle strukturellen Reformen an ja wir
machen jetzt auch ernst mit dem Thema
Bürokratieabbau denn das ist wichtig das
ist Zentrale in diesem Land das Leben
viel zu viele Unternehmen da muss man
aber auch mal konkret werden und nicht
immer drüber reden sie hatten 16 Jahre
Zeit außer reden haben sie nichts
geschafft
und wir arbeiten an der öffentlichen
Infrastruktur in diesem Land ich möchte
Ihnen eine Geschichte aus dem Sauerland
erzählen von der Talbrücke rammelte bei
Lüdenscheid das ist oder wahr eine 450
Meter lange Autobahnbrücke der A4 ab 45
wieso marode war dass sie mittlerweile
gesprengt werden musste der ganze
Verkehr der zieht jetzt durch die Dörfer
die Anwohner sind verzweifelt angesichts
des Lärms und der Lkw-Fahrer waren die
vor ihrer Haustür durchfahren die
Wirtschaft vor Ort die leidet unter den
massiven Umwegen die die LKWs machen
müssen um irgendwo noch anzukommen wer
an dieser Stelle spart wer die
Investitionen in die Zukunft unserer
Infrastruktur von Nasen vernachlässigt
so wie sie das über viele Jahrzehnte
gemacht haben der gefährdet den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland die
Brücke im Sauerland ist zum Symbol
geworden für ihre Tapete
Wirtschaftspolitik
und wenn wir über die Herausforderungen
reden die wirtschaftspolitisch vor uns
stehen dann sollten wir uns auch auf
diejenigen konzentrieren die die
Unterstützung jetzt am meisten brauchen
und das sind die energieutensiven
Unternehmen in diesem Land das sind die
Großen und die Kleinen die stehen im
internationalen Wettbewerb die waren
besonders betroffen von der russischen
Energiekrise die Leiden jetzt unter den
hohen Preisen und ich spreche einfach
eine Einladung aus weil ich weiß dass es
in verschiedenen Fraktionen in diesem
Parlament noch Debatten darüber gibt ob
ein industriestrompreis ob ein
brückenstromkreis die richtige Antwort
ist ich spreche die Einladung aus weil
am Ende müssen wir eine Frage
beantworten Stahl Chemie und Aluminium
die wird es weiterhin geben die werden
irgendwo auf der Welt hergestellt die
Frage ist nur ob die auch in Deutschland
weiterhin hergestellt werden und wir
Grünen wir sagen ganz klar wir wollen
das weil wir daran glauben das ist gut
bezahlte Facharbeiter Jobs in diesem
Land braucht
Freude daran glauben dass unsere
Industrie gut aufgestellt ist
hochinnovativ und bereit auf dem Sprung
zu einer grünen Zukunft und wenn wir mal
Zusammenhalt reden dann müssen wir auch
über Sozialpolitik reden denn die hohen
Preise in diesem Land die Treffen nicht
alle Menschen gleich die treffen
insbesondere diejenigen am härtesten die
am wenigsten haben und deshalb ist es
richtig und deswegen bin ich so froh
dass diese Regierung mit der Anpassung
der Regelsätze an die Inflation jetzt
das macht was angemessen und notwendig
ist wenn Lebensmittel wenn Kleidung wenn
all das was man fürs Leben braucht
teurer wird dann müssen die Regelsätze
angepasst werden dann ist das keine
Bestrafung der hat arbeitenden
Gesellschaft dann ist das einfach nur
die Sicherung des menschenwürdigen
Existenzminimums die uns das Grundgesetz
schon aufgegeben hat
unter März es ist total einfach sich aus
der privilegierten Position eines Mannes
der sein Leben lang sehr sehr gut
verdient hat hinzustellen und auf
diejenigen herabzuschauen den es im
Leben nicht so gut gegangen ist es ist
falsch aber es ist vor allen Dingen auch
unehrlich denn die Anpassung die wir
jetzt vornehmen die geht auf eine Reform
zurück der sie selbst noch vor wenigen
Monaten zugestimmt haben die Reform des
Bürgergeldes ist mit ihren Stimmen und
mit den Stimmen aller unionsgeführten
Regierung in diesem Land verabschiedet
worden und dass sie sich jetzt vor die
Kamera stellen und so tun als ob sie
damit nichts mehr zu tun hätten ich
frage mich geht das Wort der
konservativen Partei in diesem Land
immer nur bis zum Sommer
und das zweite was mir bei Ihnen
auffällt sie entdecken ihr Herz für
diejenigen die hart arbeiten und
trotzdem mit wenig Geld am Ende des
Monats nach Hause kommen immer nur dann
wenn es darum geht gegen diejenigen zu
polemisieren denen es noch schlechter
geht ich frage mich ganz ehrlich was
hilft es der Altenpflegerin die jeden
morgen früh aufsteht und dafür sorgt
dass die Generation ihrer Eltern und
meiner Großeltern eine gute Versorgung
bekommt wenn sie das nicht mehr alleine
schaffen was hilft es der wenn es den
Menschen in der Grundsicherung noch
schlechter geht das einzige was ihr
helfen würde ist dass wir dafür sorgen
dass sie bessere Löhne bekommt und dass
sie unterstützt wird mit den Kosten die
sie in ihrem Alltag hat diese Vorschläge
machen sie aber nicht
sie haben heute gesagt die CDU möchte
die Kinder Grundsicherung stoppen was
für ein Signal gerade für die Frauen in
diesem Land die zum Beispiel das Gehalt
einer Altenpflegerin haben denn die sind
diejenigen die insbesondere von der
Kindergrundsicherung erreicht werden
Menschen die jeden Tag arbeiten gehen
und trotzdem nicht genug verdienen um
die Miete die Winterschuhe und
vielleicht auch mal den Zoobesuch für
die Kinder finanzieren zu können die
nicht mal wussten in der Vergangenheit
dass sie Anspruch auf eine Unterstützung
haben die höher ist als das Kindergeld
das ändern wir jetzt damit machen wir
Schluss mit der größten
sozialpolitischen Reform seit vielen
Jahren weil wir endlich einfach machen
dass das Geld bei den Kindern ankommt
und man muss schon sagen wenn sie dann
immer wieder sagen am Ende geht es nicht
um Leistungsverbesserungen sondern es
geht vielleicht um Arbeitsanreize für
diejenigen die im unteren
Einkommensbereich sind der
Altenpflegerin zu sagen macht doch
einfach einen anderen Job oder geht doch
mehr arbeiten das ist zynisch und das
ist so lange wie es uns nicht leisten
diese Altenpflegerin besser zu bezahlen
auch einfach gesellschaftspolitisch eine
Antwort
sie können mit uns dafür sorgen dass es
den Menschen im unteren
Einkommensbereich besser geht sie hätten
zum Beispiel für die Erhöhung des
Mindestlohnes bestimmen können im
letzten Jahr diese Koalition hat das
gemacht sie haben es nicht gemacht sie
könnten sich für einen Tarif treuegesetz
entscheiden damit endlich Schluss ist
damit dass der Staat bei seiner
öffentlichen Auftragsvergabe auch noch
tariflucht belohnt das wäre eine
Einladung die ich jetzt an sie
ausspreche denn gute Tarifbindung ist
der beste Garant dafür dass die Menschen
ihren Jobs auch gut verdienen und mit
einem Tarif treuegesetz schaffen wir
genau diese Anreize das ist in Zukunft
mehr Tarifverträge in diesem Land gibt
und ganz zum Schluss einfach noch einmal
ein Appell an die Unionsfraktion wir
brauchen Zusammenhalt in diesem Land und
dafür brauchen wir
uns alle auch sie wir brauchen eine
konservative Partei die sagen kann
Berlin Kreuzberg ist Deutschland genauso
wie das bayerische Bierzelt wir brauchen
eine konservative Partei die sagen kann
der Christopher Street Day ist
Deutschland genauso wie die Bayreuther
Festspiele und wir brauchen eine
konservative Partei die sagen kann der
Islam gehört zu Deutschland genauso wie
der Evangelische Kirchentag sie waren da
schon mal ich kann sie nur herzlich
einladen kommen sie wieder zurück
das war Katharina dröge die
Fraktionsvorsitzende von Bündnis 90 die
Grünen mit heftiger Kritik vor allem an
Friedrich Merz der das wichtige Thema
Wirtschaft noch nicht mal angesprochen
habe Deutschland steht besser da als
dargestellt die Energiekrise habe man
gemeistert Fachkräftemangel und
Bürokratieabbau gehe die Ampel jetzt an
nächste Rednerin ist Amira Mohammed Ali
die noch Vorsitzende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der linke die
bereits angekündigt hat nicht erneut als
Kandidatin für den Fraktionsvorsitz zu
kandidieren
und für die Fraktion DIE LINKE hat nun
das Wort Amira Mohammed Ali
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr Herr
Bundeskanzler ich finde schon
erstaunlich wie sie die Probleme in
unserem Land herrschen klein reden und
gleichzeitig ergotten schlechtes
Regierungshandeln
laut aktuellen Umfragen sind dreiviertel
der Bevölkerung mit der Arbeit der
Bundesregierung unzufrieden und wissen
Sie wie viele laut ARD Deutschland
trennt mit ihrer Arbeit sehr zufrieden
sind
0%. das muss man auch erstmal schaffen
leider ist das kein Wunder alles ist
teurer geworden Lebensmittel Strom Sprit
Heizung Schulsachen Schulausflüge
Urlaubsreisen der Kinobesuch die
Eintrittskarte fürs Schwimmbad die die
vorher schon wenig hatten verzweifeln
und die Angst nicht mehr über die Runden
zu kommen frisst sich immer tiefer in
die Mittelschicht hinein ihre spärlichen
Hilfsmaßnahmen haben nicht dazu geführt
dass die Lage sich entspannt gar nicht
vielleicht können sie wenigstens das mal
einräumen wäre ja ein erster Schritt zur
Besserung
zu Recht sind viele wütend darüber dass
sie auf der einen Seite Milliarden für
Rüstung einfach raushauen und den
Aktionären von Rheinmetall und Co den
reibbach ihres Lebens bescheren auf der
anderen Seite aber überall sonst
knausern und sparen bis es quietscht bis
es knarzt bis es bricht aber das geht so
nicht
2,8 Millionen Kinder in Deutschland sind
in Armut sie haben versprochen das ist
eine Kindergrundsicherung geben wird die
Schluss macht mit der Kinderarmut damit
es eben nicht mehr so ist dass Kinder
ohne Pausenbrot zur Schule gehen und
sich den Sportverein nicht leisten
können dass kein Kind wegen der
finanziellen Nöte der Eltern mehr
abgehängt wird ihre Familienministerin
Frau Pausch hat ausgerechnet das ist 12
Milliarden Euro bräuchte um hier
einigermaßen wirksame Abhilfe zu
schaffen 12 Milliarden Euro das ist
übrigens gerade mal ein Viertel das
Militäretat nur einmal die Dimension
klar zu machen und was gibt's jetzt
tatsächlich was kommt wirklich
2,4 Milliarden ich meine man muss kein
Raketenwissenschaftler sein um
festzustellen das ist nur ein Fünftel
der von der Regierung selbst als
notwendig erachteten Summe Frau hat auch
schon zugegeben Frau Pause hat auch
schon zugegeben dass das zu wenig ist
und für Kinder reale Verbesserungen zu
bewirken und sie stellen sich hier
ernsthaft hin und geben sich stolz ob
dieses Etiketten schwindet den sie
Kinder wollen Sicherungen nennen ihn ist
wirklich gar nichts peinlich sie sollten
Sie verstehen
und Finanzminister Lindner der sagt
sogar dass das die letzte größere
Sozialreformen dieser Wahlperiode sein
wird wow das nennen sie Sozialreformen
auch noch größere und jetzt kommt nichts
mehr ich finde das wirklich ein neuer
Tiefpunkt und das wird auch nicht
dadurch besser dass sie Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von SPD und Grünen sich jetzt
alle hinter Christian Lindner verstecken
und in den schwarzen Peter zuschieben
wollen weil er das Geld nicht locker
macht nein das haben sie alle gemeinsam
zu verantworten und nicht so ungut nicht
im Gegensatz zu ihnen behauptet die FDP
ja wenigstens nicht eine soziale Partei
zu sein da sind sie immer ehrlich fakt
ist ihre Politik sorgt nicht für
Sicherheit im Gegenteil und deswegen ein
kurzes Wort zum vermursten
heizungsgesetz weiterhin halten sie fest
an diesem Quatsch für das dass der das
Klima kaum schützen würde aber Menschen
in unserem Land verunsichert und ärmer
macht auf die Frage mit wie viel CO2
Einsparungen die Bundesregierung in
eigentlich rechnet wenn das
heizungsgesetz so umgesetzt wird wie Sie
es wünschen antwortet die
Bundesregierung mit 1,4 % bis 2030 wenn
es gut läuft darüber reden wir hier und
dafür regieren sie den Menschen in ihren
Heizungskeller hinein das ist nicht nur
übergriffig das ist absurd
dafür sollen mieten schreiben Kommunen
belastet werden und Hausbesitzer bluten
und wie die Förderung für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ganz konkret
aussieht wie man sein Geld konnte
welchen Zeitrahmen man weiß es nicht das
regelt ihr Gesetz nämlich gar nicht klar
ist nur gefördert wird Albert allenfalls
die Kosten für die Wärmepumpe die
Umbauten der Häuser die notwendig sind
aber nicht unmittelbar mit dem Einbau
der Wärmepumpe Zusammenhängen die werden
nicht gefördert da sollen die Leute halt
sehen wie sie klarkommen unglaublich was
sie hier abziehen nur damit Robert habe
seine gute Situation ein angeblichen
Erfolg für den Klimaschutz vorweisen
kann unfassbar
und derweil
können jeden Tag im ganzen Land Kitas
nicht öffnen wegen Personalmangels ob
Bus und Bahn einen halbwegs zuverlässig
ans Ziel bringen ist weiterhin vor allem
Glückssache wenn Bus und Bahn überhaupt
fahren Kliniken sterben weil sie nicht
rentabel genug sind der Chef der
Deutschen Krankenhausgesellschaft Gerald
Gas der erwartet dass in nächster Zeit
ein Drittel der bestehenden
Krankenhäuser schließen muss und er sagt
auch dass die krankenhausreform von der
Lauterbach diese Entwicklung nicht
stoppen sondern noch verschärfen wird
und das sind nur einige Beispiel
viele Menschen machen sich Sorgen um
ihre Zukunft und die Zukunft ihrer
Familien um ihren Arbeitsplatz um Ihr
Zuhause und nein das auszusprechen ist
kein schlecht reden unseres Landes wie
die ampelchor desionäre das gerne
behaupten es ist die Realität
Deutschland ist in einer großen
Wirtschaftskrise einer der größten in
der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik der
Internationale Währungsfonds IWF rechnet
mit einem Rückgang unserer Wirtschaft um
0,3 Prozent das Ifo-Institut sogar mit
0,4 %. kein anderes Land in der EU hat
vom IWF eine so miese Prognose bekommen
wie Deutschland und was ist die Antwort
der Bundesregierung sparen die
Schuldenbremse soll unbedingt
eingehalten werden koste es was es
wollen eine Volkswirtschaft lässt sich
aber nicht aus der Rezession
heraussparen sie kann nur aus der
Rezession heraus wachsen so ist das
Michael
der Leiter des Deutschen Instituts für
Wirtschaftsforschung sagte zu ihren
klingen dass jeder Unternehmer wissen
bei großen Herausforderungen wo man
Leute Technologien einsetzen neue
Produkte entwickeln will dann muss man
erstmal einen Kredit aufnehmen und sich
verschulden und das Geld auch für den
Staat ihr Festhalten an der
Schuldenbremse ist gegen jede Vernunft
wir dürfen jetzt nicht sparen wir
brauchen große investitions-
und bevor sie das hier reinrufen und
sagen das gäbe ist ja schon der
sogenannte Klima- und
transformationsfonds mit knapp 212
Milliarden Euro möchte ich was zu sagen
wenn man da nicht genau hinguckt dann
stellt man fest das reicht nicht das
Institut der deutschen Wirtschaft sagt
dass diese Summe bestenfalls bestenfalls
die Hälfte dessen ist was man bräuchte
und gerade mal die dringendsten
Investitionen zu finanzieren die die
Wirtschaft braucht und zukunftsfähig zu
werden
Michael Hüter Chefin vom IW bezeichnet
die Argument das Staatsschulden immer
schlechte Schulden sein als ökonomisches
Denken der 90er Jahre so viel zum Thema
fortschrittskoalition wie sicher immer
selber gerne nennen ich meine sogar
beiden der ja nur auch nicht auffallen
für Aufbruch und moderne steht sogar der
hat es verstanden die USA haben mit dem
sogenannten den Flächen reduction Act
ein großes Investitionspaket geschnürt
und die Wirtschaft umzubauen und Grüne
Zukunftstechnologien anzusehen deutsche
Unternehmen waren dann in die USA ab
weil sie dort bessere Bedingungen
vorfinden wer ist es hat bereits
stellenstreichen angekündigt und legt
eine ammoniakanlage in Ludwigshafen
steht audi plant E-Autos verstärkt in
den USA herzustellen hier geht es um
relevante Schlüsselindustrien
Deutschland da kann man doch nicht
einfach zu gucken
und es gab schon einmal es gab schon
einmal einen Kanzler der Deutschland mit
seiner Sparpolitik ruiniert hat Heinrich
Brüning Reichskanzler der Weimarer
Republik von 1930 bis 1932 und wohin das
geführt hat und welche politischen
Kräfte dadurch stark geworden sind das
wissen wir
aus Geschichte kann man aber lernen herr
Scholz und auch das können sie tun und
das sollten Sie auch ein weiterer
Unterschied zwischen Deutschland und den
USA wenn Unternehmen dort zu Gute kommt
ist dass die Energie dort bezahlbar ist
und dass das bei uns nicht so ist das
hat Gründe und natürlich war der
russische Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine der wichtigste Auslöser diese
Entwicklung dass die Preise in
Deutschland aber so hochgegangen sind
und blieben ist das Ergebnis falscher
politischer Entscheidungen dieser
Bundesregierung und jetzt kommen Sie
bitte nicht mit ihrem Stromkreis Deckel
der kam viel zu spät und greift erst bei
viel zu hohen Preisen andere Regierung
waren da klüger Spanien und Frankreich
z.B
denn bevor ist da zu den großen Teuerung
kam hat man harte preisdeckel für
Energie eingeführt und obwohl diese
beiden Länder richtigerweise auch wie
Deutschland den Krieg in der Ukraine
klar verurteilen importieren Sie im
großen Stil das vergleichsweise günstige
Energie Gas aus Russland in diesem Jahr
sogar noch mehr als im Vorjahr wie
gerade vorgestern die Zeitschrift Agrar
heute berichtet hat im Ergebnis fällt
das Bruttoinlandsprodukt dort deutlich
besser aus als bei uns
ich erinnere mich noch an die Worte von
einer beerbock dass die Sanktionen die
russische Wirtschaft ruinieren werden
und ich weiß auch noch was ich was
andere die das gesagt haben
wie die mit Schimpf und Schande
überschüttet worden sind wenn man die
Wahrheit ausspricht dass diese
Sanktionen der deutschen Wirtschaft
erheblich schaden werden der russischen
aber nicht Kreml Propaganda und alles
mögliche wurde uns vorgeworfen wir
stellen fest die russische Wirtschaft
wächst um 1,5% in diesem Jahr
offensichtlich hat inzwischen auch Frau
Weber erkannt und einräumen müssen dass
die Sanktionen der russischen Wirtschaft
nicht wirklich geschadet haben
aber folgt auf dieser Erkenntnis jetzt
eine Handlung überdenkt man die falsche
Politik die man gemacht hat ich fürchte
nein stattdessen sagen Sie nun das
Sanktionen nur in Demokratien und
zivilisierten Ländern wirken
Sachkompetenz
haben sie damit eigentlich auch
anerkannt dass Koba eine Demokratie ist
ich meine da wirken die
wirtschaftsaktion der USA los erheblich
auf die Wirtschaft aber vielleicht
klären wir das ein andermal ihre
Regierungsarbeit herr Scholz die ist
geprägt durch öffentlichen Streit durch
Unvernunft und durch Unehrlichkeit herr
Scholz wenn Sie wollen dass Deutschland
eine relevante Industrienation bleibt
dann müssen sie ihren Kurs korrigieren
die Fraktionsvorsitzende der Linken
Amira Mohammed Ali konzertiert der Ampel
grottenschlechtes regieren alles sei
teurer geworden 2,8 Millionen Kinder
würden in Armut leben aber zeitgleich
große Summen in die Verteidigung
investiert nur 2,4 Milliarden für die
Kinder Grundsicherung als letzte soziale
Tat sei ein Skandal es folgt Christian
dürr der FDP Fraktionsvorsitzende
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kollegen und Kollegen seit eineinhalb
Jahren führt Russland diesen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine Menschen
sterben seit 559 Tagen kämpfen die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer mutig für ihr
Land und eben auch für unsere Freiheit
wir sehen erste auch militärische
Erfolge glücklicherweise der Durchbruch
der russischen Verteidigungslinie ist
einer solcher die Gegenoffensive der
Ukraine war an dieser Stelle erfolgreich
auch dank der militärischen
Unterstützung des Westens und wir aus
Deutschland mit unserem militärischen
Material wir helfen Menschenleben zu
retten denken Sie beispielsweise an das
System ihres Tee und andere das ist das
was jetzt zu tun ist und ich bin dankbar
dass die breite Mehrheit in Deutschland
genau hinter dieser Politik steht das
muss man an einem solchen Tag sagen
ich will Herr Merz aber dennoch direkt
in dem Zusammenhang natürlich auch die
Haushaltspolitik zu sprechen kommen die
sie hier zu Recht eben auch erwähnt
haben
und ich will mit einem Punkt jetzt
aufräumen weil in mehreren Debatten
haben sie das hier eingeführt und es
entspricht schlichtig den Tatsache wenn
wir in dieser Bundesregierung das zwei
Prozent Ziel der NATO sofort nach
Regierungsübernahme und nach Ausbruch
dieser fürchterlichen Krieges im
Kernhaus hätten darstellen können dann
hätte es eine Sondervermögens für die
Bundeswehr ja gar nicht gebraucht dieses
Sondervermögen was wir
dankenswerterweise mit einer 2/3
Mehrheit im Deutschen Bundestag
beschlossen haben gewährleistet in den
kommenden Jahren das zwei Prozent Ziel
und der Bundeskanzler hat auch über den
Anschluss danach gesprochen das ist die
Einigkeit Herr März alles andere im
Haushaltstitel von der Historie ist
jetzt rumzusuchen macht keinen Sinn war
nicht verabredet ich will an dieser
Stelle einfach mal außer tierisch damit
aufhören damit alle Klarheit haben an
dieser Stelle liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen alles andere ist nicht richtig
ernährt muss ausgesprochen werden
es ist gleichwohl natürlich nach wie vor
eine herausfordernde Zeit nach vielen
auch krisenbedingten Haushalten
insbesondere während der corona-pandemie
seit 2020 in ihrer
Regierungsverantwortung hat der Bund
einen ganzen Haushalt an zusätzlichen
Schulden gemacht müssen wir aus diesem
Modus herauskommen wir müssen nach vorne
schauen wir müssen zur finanzpolitischen
Normalität zurückkehren und übrigens
deshalb kaum erwähnt bisher es ist eine
gute Entscheidung des Finanzministers
von den vielen Sondervermögen die wir
übrigens von ihnen geerbt haben jetzt
mit diesem Bundeshaushalt ganz konkret
drei Sondervermögen auch mal wieder
abzuschaffen ja das Sondervermögen für
die Bundeswehr war notwendig zu unserer
Regierungszeit aber wir konzentrieren
uns auf den Kernhaushalt des Bundes und
halten die Schuldenbremse zum zweiten
Mal ein ohne
steuererhöhungsvorschläge der Union
liebe Kollegen auch das ist eine gute
Botschaft
und wir setzen Schwerpunkte mit diesem
Haushalt liebe Kollegen die
Investitionsquote dieser Bundesregierung
im Bundeshaushalt steigt auf 12,2
Prozent im Vergleich zum
Vorkrisen-Niveau also dem letzten
normalen Bundeshaushalt der großen
Koalition wo die Investitionsquote noch
10,9% betragen hat das geht in die
richtige Richtung wir setzen sehr klar
Prioritäten beispielsweise beim
wachstumschancengesetz des
Finanzministers ich komme gleich in
Bezug auf die Union noch einmal drauf zu
sprechen und drittens wie entlasten die
Wirtschaft und sorgen für Impulse
insbesondere um den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland zu stärken und verzichten
auf Steuererhöhung liebe Kollegen ich
will auch genau diesen
Wirtschaftsstandort zu sprechen kommen
weil die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unseres
Landes in den letzten Monaten
richtigerweise Thema war ja und wir
stehen da vor großen Herausforderungen
und deswegen liebe Kollegen Kollegen was
richtig nachdem anderthalb Jahrzehnte
faktisch keine echte Wirtschaftsreform
Politik in Deutschland gefunden hat das
muss man einmal aussprechen glaube ich
deswegen war es richtig dass das
Bundeskabinett auf Schloss Meseberg das
wachstumschancengesetz des
Finanzministers beschlossen hat immerhin
mit einem Entlastungsvolumen von
jährlich 7 Milliarden Euro deswegen war
es richtig dass das Bundeskabinett in
die Zukunft schaut und das
zukunftsfinanzierungsgesetz beschlossen
hat wo es um Start-ups geht wo es darum
geht dass
mitarbeiterkapitalbeteiligung auch
endlich im Gesetz steht und deswegen war
es richtig dass wir zurzeit im Deutschen
Bundestag über planungsbeschleunigung
sprechen auch das viele Jahrzehnte
besprochen und deswegen war es richtig
dass der Bundesjustizminister ein großen
Vorschlag für ein großes Bürokratie
Entlastungspaket dieser Bundesregierung
gemacht hat liebe Kollegen Kollegen wir
würden mit diesem Paket auf ein allzeit
Minimum was die Bürokratie Kosten des
Bundes betrifft kommen das sollten wir
tun wir sollten endlich ernst machen und
der Bundeskanzler hat ein packt
angekündigt der Bundestag hat die
Möglichkeit diesen bürok ratie
entlassungsgesetz von Marco Buschmann
bereits einzulösen das ist die richtige
Botschaft liebe Kollegen Kollegen
und
ich will deshalb bei dem Thema bleiben
war ja richtig in der Sommerpause viele
haben Unternehmen besucht und der
Mittelständler um die Ecke sagt genau
das es sind die Bürokratiekosten
Fachkräftemangel Energiekosten ich komme
darauf später noch aber es sind die
Bürokratiekosten die ein Problem da sind
und jetzt müssen wir über Deutschland
hinausschauen
57 Prozent der Bürokratiekosten der
Unternehmen in Deutschland ich saß in
der Deutlichkeit die kommen aus Brüssel
und liebe Kollegen Kollegen der Union da
nehme ich sie in die Pflicht wir werden
in Deutschland alles tun um die deutsche
Wirtschaft bei der Bürokratie zu
entlasten aber ich erwarte ich erwarte
geradezu dass Ursula von der Leyen am
kommenden Mittwoch bei ihrer Rede zur
Lage der Union der Europäischen Union
genau dieses Thema anspricht und in
diesem Pakt in der Bundeskanzler
angekündigt hat wo wir mit Frankreich im
Dialog sein werden genau in diesem Pakt
einsteigt ist wird für die deutsche
Wirtschaft im Herzen Europas nur
funktionieren wenn wir unseren Job
machen das haben wir zugesagt aber ich
erwarte von der kommissionspräsidentin
dass sie auch endlich beim Bürokratie
Abbau ihren Job machen liebe Kollegen
diese Erwartungen müssen wir haben in
Deutschland
aber natürlich müssen wir beide
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit darüber
hinausdenken ich sagte es vorhin schon
bei den Stromkosten es gibt höchst
unterschiedliche Konzepte ich denn sagen
wir ein bisschen überrascht in den
letzten Tagen gewesen dass trotz dem
Herr März hier als Parteivorsitzender
der Union gesagt hat dass die Grünen der
Hauptgegner sein jetzt politisch an der
Stelle jedenfalls liebe Kollegen der
Grünen beim Thema industriestrompreis
man inhaltlich als Fraktionsvorsitzender
Friedrich Merzig auf sie zu bewegt gut
dass die FDP dazwischen Sitz will ich an
dieser Stelle sagen aber das nur das nur
nebenbei ähm ich glaube nicht ich glaube
nicht dass eine neue Subvention beim
Preis das Richtige ist sondern wir
wissen bei den Abgaben runter deswegen
glaube ich müssen wir über die
stromsteuersenkung sprechen wir könnten
Sie auf das europäische Minimum
reduzieren wir müssen auch über den
Spitzenausgleich sprechen der natürlich
eine Herausforderung ist wenn der
ausläuft insbesondere für eine
energieintensive in der
energieintensiven Unternehmen in
Deutschland und wir müssen in dem
Zusammenhang Liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen
natürlich darüber sprechen wie wir
insgesamt bei der Energiepolitik das was
wir als technologieoffenheit markiert
haben in einigen Gesetzen bereits auch
in Zukunft Fortleben werden wir haben
das heizungsgesetz gesprochen wir haben
Entscheidungen getroffen insbesondere
zum Verbrennungsmotor und vieles mehr
ich habe gehört dass die
bundesaußenministerin im Rahmen der
Botschafterkonferenz auch über
rohstoffpartnerschaften gesprochen hat
und nicht unterstreiche das ausdrücklich
70 Prozent der Primärenergie der
viertgrößten volkswirtschafter der Welt
der Exportnation Deutschland 70 Prozent
importieren wir und ich wage die
Prognose das wird in Zukunft auch so
sein wir sind darauf angewiesen diese
Partnerschaften zu haben beispielsweise
bei synthetischen Kraftstoff und
deswegen ist es richtig dass der
Bundesverkehrsminister auf der IAA ein
Schwerpunkt bei efuelsgesetz hat liebe
Kollegen auch das gewährleistet oder
energiepolitische Sicherheit in der
Zukunft und das ist doch zentral eine
solche Schlüsselindustrie also es geht
um die Erhaltung des Wohlstands um
Schlüsselindustrien wie beispielsweise
die Automobilindustrie wir wollen in
Richtung Klimaneutralität aber wir
wollen eben das insbesondere durch
technologieoffenheit gewährleisten wir
treffen die Entscheidung beispielsweise
zu synthetischen Kraftstoffen in der
Bundesregierung Kraftstoffe die zu
Zeiten der Unionsregierung verboten
waren aber ich erwarte auch dort ich
erwarte auch dort liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Union ihre Unterstützung im
Bezug auf das was vor von der Leyen in
der Europäischen Kommission tut wir
werden synthetische Kraftstoffe in
Reinform an öffentlichen Tankstellen in
Deutschland zulassen wir werden also
dafür sorgen dass das möglich ist wir
werden rohstoffpartnerschaften
abschließen aber wir können es nicht
dulden und wir wollen es nicht zulassen
das nach wie vor einigen der Kommission
auch die Kommissionspräsidenten das Ziel
hat den Verbrennungsmotor zu verbieten
das wäre das falsche Signal wir brauchen
alle Technologien
insbesondere Klimaneutralität zu
erreichen und erwarte ich ihre
Unterstützung liebe Kollegen Kollegen
der CDU ist
also
an der Stelle hat auch da will ich
darüber hinausgehen an der Stelle hat
der der Bundesfinanzminister eine ganz
wichtige Ankündigung gemacht er hat
gesagt
Klimaneutralität und
technologieoffenheit das muss ich auch
im Steuerrecht widerspielen wir haben
das in der Koalition bereits politisch
beschlossen und wir werden jetzt dazu in
die Gesetzgebung gehen nämlich dass wir
unabhängig davon wo der Kraftstoff
herkommt ausschließlich darauf achten
dass der klimaneutral ist und deswegen
ist es vollkommen richtig die
Elektromobilität die genauso ein Platz
hat wie andere Technologien die
Elektromobilität genauso zu behandeln
wie wir in Zukunft beispielsweise den
Antrieb mit synthetischen Kraftstoffen
steuerlich behandeln werden bei der
Kfz-Steuer und so weiter und sofort das
ist das was wir in Deutschland für
technologieoffenheit tun können
insbesondere auch im Sinne einer
Energiepolitik die diesen Standort
Stärken diese Dinge gehören zusammen
liebe Kollegen
und ich will in dem Punkt
auf etwas zweites zu sprechen natürlich
geht es auch um die Frage wie wir
unseren Wirtschaftsstandort neben den
Rahmenbedingungen neben den steuerlichen
den ordnungspolitischen
Rahmenbedingungen auch Stärken was den
Arbeitsmarkt betrifft es ist vollkommen
richtig dass ein Sozialstaat
selbstverständlich die Schwachen und die
ärmeren die schwieriger gerade am Beginn
ihres Lebens im Blick hat und deswegen
werden wir die Kindergrundsicherung auf
dem Weg bringen mit dem klaren Fokus das
familienpolitische Leistungen einfacher
zugänglich werden richtig ist
gleichzeitig dass die Erwerbstätigkeit
der Eltern die zentrale Herausforderung
ist und Kinderarmut zu bekämpfen und an
dieser Stelle werden wir einiges tun und
ich bin dankbar dass auch der
Bundesarbeitsminister beispielsweise
gesagt hat dass wir natürlich in dem
Zusammenhang gemerkt über das Thema
Arbeitsanreize sprechen werden aber ich
will nicht unerwähnt lassen was diese
Regierungskoalition bereits durch den
Deutschen Bundestag gebracht hat denn es
ist ja richtig es muss sich Lohn
ranzupfen es muss unintelligible
beispielsweise für einen jungen Menschen
lohnen eine Ausbildung anzufangen und
richtig ist doch Herr Merz dass zu ihrer
Regierungszeit ein junger Mensch der aus
einer Familie kommt die Schwert weil sie
beispielsweise im Leistungsbezug von
damals Hartz IV war ein junger Mensch
der eine Ausbildung gestartet hat dürfte
von seiner Ausbildungsvergütung gerade
mal 300 Euro behalten diese
Regierungskoalition hat es zu Recht
entschieden dass es sich endlich lohnt
eine Ausbildung anzufangen dieser junge
Mensch kann jetzt 700 Euro behalten das
ist soziale Gerechtigkeit in Verbindung
mit arbeitseinreizen und deswegen
verstehe ich nicht warum sie dort den
Arbeitsanweisungen polymisieren als
Union
und ich will einen zweiten Punkt
ansprechen das betrifft die
Bildungschancen junger Menschen es ist
doch vollkommen richtig das gerade junge
Menschen die schwere am Leben haben am
Start ihres Lebens die besten
Ausgangsbedingungen brauchen und
deswegen ist das staatschancenprogramm
der bundesforschungs- und
Bildungsministerin Bettina stark
batzinger so richtig in
Nordrhein-Westfalen ist uns einer
Koalition zwischen Union und FDP haben
wir das mit den talentschulen sehr
erfolgreich umgesetzt wir sollten das
bundesweit machen wir sollten bundesweit
mit diesem Staat chancen-programm
endlich durchstarten und da ist meine
herzliche Bitte im Sinne des der
Zusammenarbeit die der Bundeskanzlerin
seiner Rede markiert hat da ist meine
herzliche Bitte dass sie auch auf ihre
Länderkollegen zu gehen ich sag mal in
der Deutlichkeit weil es mich ärgert
dieses mimimi der
landeskultusminister und mancher
Ministerpräsidenten das regt mich
langsam auf Bildung ist eine nationale
Anstrengung und wir leisten unseren
Beitrag ich erwarte von den Ländern auch
von den Regierten dass sie endlich
mitmachen dann statt Chancen dass sie
mitmachen bei der Digitalisierung der
Schulen dass sie mitmachen dass Menschen
mehr Chancen hat und besser im
Arbeitsmarkt unterwegs sind liebe
Kollegen
und zum Schluss wir müssen natürlich in
die Zukunft denken auch was den Haushalt
betrifft der Bundesfinanzminister hat
gestern zu Recht gesagt dass es an der
Stelle darum geht Eisberge frühzeitig zu
erkennen und richtigerweise zum Schiffen
der Bundeshaushalt hat nach wie vor und
wird in Zukunft eine große
Herausforderung bei die demografischen
Lasten haben das ist nicht die Schuld
der ältere Generation sondern es ist
auch die Verantwortung übrigens auch
meiner Partei Regierungsverantwortung in
führen Legislaturperioden zu wenig
Vorsorge getroffen zu haben aber in dem
Zusammenhang fand ich es schon spannend
verehrter Herr Merz als ich die Zeitung
aufschlug und in Bezug auf die
gesetzliche aktienrente also das
generationenkapital als Vorschlag des
Finanzministers als sich dort las das
sein hedgefondsmethoden weil meine
Intuition war
hat sich da ein Koalitionspartner
irgendwie kritisch geäußert nein das war
nicht so dann war mir klar es muss von
der Linkspartei kommen hätte ich von
Methoden wenn es darum geht die
gesetzliche Rentenversicherung endlich
zukunftsfit und Enkel zu machen
Patchwork mit so wissen Sie wer von
Hedgefonds Methoden gesprochen hat wenn
wir über das generationenkapital
sprechen also die zentrale demografische
Herausforderung die Frage ob Menschen in
Zukunft in Würde altern können und die
Beitragslast nicht steigen von hatchimal
Methoden sprach der Fraktionsvorsitzende
der cdu/csu wie weit links sind sie denn
gerückt an dieser Stelle es ist
unglaublich ich kann es nicht fassen ich
kann es nicht fassen
ja die liegt Partei gibt ihnen recht
also liebe Kollegen Kollegen zum
Abschluss meine herzliche Bitte ist dass
wir diese Herausforderung bei der
Bürokratie bei der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
unseres Landes auch bei der Bildung
gemeinsam anfassen wir haben erste
Schritte getan bei der Entlastung der
Mitte beispielsweise durch das
inflationsausgleichsgesetz aber eine
Chimäre funktioniert nicht wir halten
die Schulden bringen sie richtigerweise
ein das werden wir auch in den kommenden
Jahren tun aber bitte und auch da meine
herzliche an die cdu/csu hören sie auf
in einem Land das die höchsten Steuern
hat über Steuererhöhungen zu reden liebe
Kollegen Kollegen der Spitzensteuersatz
ich sage das deshalb in der Deutlichkeit
weil sie ja selbst mittlerweile gegen
vermeintlich reichere politisieren der
Spitzensteuersatz in Deutschland ist bei
der Einkommensteuer in aller Regel die
Unternehmenssteuer für kleine
Unternehmen für Einzelunternehmer und
Personengesellschaften das sind 2,4
Millionen Menschen die für Jobs sorgen
die jeden Morgen ran klotzen die Zahlen
denen den ernsthaft in ihrem Konzept auf
57% faktisch erhöhen zu wollen ist ein
Unding das ist das Gegenteil von
Leistungsgerechtigkeit wir stehen für
leistungsrechtlichkeit in dieser
Regierung ich danke Ihnen
das war Christian Dörr von der FDP der
natürlich den Haushalt seines
Parteivorsitzenden Christian Lindner
verteidigt die Schuldenbremse sei
richtig und er wehrt sich vehement gegen
Steuererhöhungen der vom Bundeskanzler
Scholz vorgeschlagene Deutschland packt
sei der richtige Weg angefangen habe man
jetzt mit dem Gesetz zum Bürokratieabbau
strittig bleibt in der Ampel aber das
Thema industriestrompreis auch das wurde
hier deutlich es folgt Alexander
Dobrindt Vorsitzender der CSU
Landesgruppe frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
der Bundeskanzler nach einer aktuellen
Umfrage des allenbach-instituts glauben
nur noch 10% der Bürger dass die
ampelpolitik dieses Land voranbringen
wird sie regieren an die Probleme der
Menschen vorbei sie Regierenden
Herausforderungen dieses Landes vorbei
sie reden an den Sorgen der Bürger
vorbei dieses Land braucht Antworten auf
Inflationsangst auf Energiepreise auf
Wohlstandsverlust bekommen Thomas von
ihnen Cannabis selbstbestimmungsgesetz
und Express Einbürgerung das ist das
Gegenteil von Fortschritt das ist
Abstieg meine Damen und Herren
und dabei haben sie heute gesprochen von
Kaufkraft gewinnen die bei den
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmern zu
verzeichnen während des Ifo-Institut
bestätigt diese Woche dass es einen
Rückgang der Inflation nur ganz ganz C
gibt und wir länger mit dieser Inflation
noch leben müssen und das heißt dass die
Belastungen der mittleren und kleinen
Einkommen durch die Inflation sich
weiter aufbauen wer zu Beginn ihrer
Wahlperiode Herr Bundeskanzler seinen
Wocheneinkauf für 100 € bezahlt hat der
muss heute dafür
130 Euro ausgeben das trifft die
Familien das trifft die mittleren und
kleinen Einkommen das trifft die Rentner
die Inflation ist die Enteignung der
mittleren und kleinen Einkommen ob am
Monatsende der Kühlschrank voll ist oder
leer ist entscheidet sich genau an
dieser Stelle unter verweisen sie darauf
dass es Kaufkraft Gewinne gibt das ist
das Gegenteil von dem was stattfindet
tun sie etwas gegen die Enteignung der
kleine und bitteren Einkommen und zeigen
sie die Mehrwertsteuer Wundermittel
der Bundeskanzler sie haben in ihrer
Rede bevor sie uns einen Pakt angeboten
haben erstmal einen Kompromiss
aufgekündigt sie haben in ihrer Rede der
Zeitenwende davon gesprochen dass diese
100 Milliarden für die Bundeswehr
zusätzlich zur Verfügung stehen wir
haben diesen Kompromiss mit ihnen
geschlossen zusätzlich zur Verfügung
stehen heute haben sie uns vorgeworfen
wir würden diesen Kompromiss aufkündigen
ich sage Ihnen Herr Bundeskanzler wir
stehen weiterhin zu diesem Kompromiss es
ist ihre ampelregierung die nicht mehr
zu diesen Kompromiss steht
und möglicherweise haben Sie den Bericht
des Bundesrechnungshof von gestern noch
nicht lösen können vor ihrer Rede der
bestätigt nämlich genau das wörtlich es
läuft dem Zweck des
verfassungsgesetzgebers entgegen dass
sie jetzt versuchen die Verwendung zu
verändern der Bundesrechnungshof hält es
für rechtlich unzulässig dass sie die
Verwendung jetzt verändern sie kündigen
den Kompromiss auf weil sie dieses Geld
eben nicht mehr zusätzlich für die
großen Beschaffungen verwenden wollen
sie wollen es im normalen Haushalt
verbraten und bringen damit die
Bundeswehr und die Ausrüstung
der Bundeskanzler trotzdem war
beachtlich dass sie heute von einer
nationalen Kraftanstrengung gesprochen
haben dass sie von einem Deutschland
packt gesprochen haben dass sie von
Kooperation statt Streitereien
gesprochen haben ich war mir in dem
Moment nicht sicher an wen sich dieser
Satz eigentlich richten sollte
vermutlich an ihre eigene Koalition was
die Streitereien anbelangt der
Dauerstreit scheint ja zum Normalzustand
geworden zu sein aber ich würde sagen
beenden Sie als erstes mal die
Streitereien in ihrem eigenen Laden über
Energiepreise über Kernenergie über
Kindergrundsicherung dann können wir uns
darüber unterhalten nur mit uns
kooperieren kann
nichtsdestotrotz ich glaube dass man in
einer Lage in der sich unser Land
befindet durchaus dieses Angebot von
ihnen ernst nehmen sollte und ich sage
Ihnen auch wir sind durchaus bereit mit
Ihnen auch eine Kooperation oder einen
Pakt auch einzugehen ich halte aber
allerdings auch fest dass dieses Angebot
deutlich zeigt dass die Gemeinsamkeiten
in ihrer Koalition ganz offensichtlich
beendet sie sind und Sie uns ein Angebot
zur Zusammenarbeit machen weil sie ihre
eigenen Ampel für zentrale Fragen keine
Mehrheit mehr sehen der Bundeskanzler
aber wenn ihre Koalition in weiten
Teilen ausfällt ja dann stehen wir
selbstverständlicherweise auch zur
Verfügung um einen Deutschland Pack zu
machen dann reden wir aber als
allererstes über eine der zentralsten
Krisen aktuell in Deutschland nämlich
über die flüchtlingskrise dann reden wir
darüber
wie wir gemeinsam diese flüchtlingskrise
bewältigen können und dazu haben wir
einen klaren Fahrplan den können Sie mit
uns sofort in der nächsten Sitzungswoche
in einen deutschland-park zur
Bewältigung dieser Krise hineinschreiben
dann lassen Sie uns darüber reden dass
wir die sicheren Herkunftsstaaten
endlich gemeinsam vereinbar nicht nur
moldaugeorgen sondern die Marke starten
mit dazu
dann lassen Sie uns doch vereinbaren
dass wir Grenzkontrollen jetzt auch bei
Polen bei Tschechien durchführen wie in
Österreich mehr als die Hälfte aller
Flüchtlinge aller illegalen einreisen
kommen über die polnische Grenze lassen
Sie uns das vereinbart ihre
Innenministerin blockiert das zurzeit
vereinbaren Sie mit uns dass wir die
Freiwilligen Aufnahmeprogramme ihre
Außenministerin sofort stoppen damit wir
den Druck auf unsere Kommunen damit auch
reduzieren können wir sind sofort dabei
vereinbaren Sie mit uns dass wir mehr
Sachleistungen weniger Geldleistung
machen vereinbaren will uns dass wir
Ausreise Gewahrsam verlängern und
vereinbaren Sie damit mit uns dass es
endlich aufhört das aus ihrer Regierung
heraus die europäischen Beschlüsse zum
außengrenzt
Verantwortung der Bundeskanzler
wir können das alles gemeinsam auch
besprechen und diskutieren aber wenn du
den Kollegen auch Taten folgen lassen
und wir erwarten dass auf uns
entsprechend zugegangen wird und genau
für diese Frage der flüchtlingskrise für
eine nächste Sitzung dann die
entsprechenden Vereinbarungen zu treffen
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage von der
Beatrix von Storch
lassen Sie diese dummen Zwischenrufen
ja sehr geehrter Dobrind vielen Dank
dass Sie die Zwischenfrage zulassen und
ich muss diese Frage die sich uns immer
und immer wieder stellt bei den ganzen
reden die sie halten insbesondere mit
Blick auf die Flüchtlingspolitik einmal
fragen
merken Sie eigentlich irgendetwas ich
meine sie fordern Grenzschutz sie
fordern Abschiebung sie fordern
Sachleistung statt Geldleistung sie
fordern alles das was wir in der letzten
Legislaturperiode durchgehend von Ihnen
gefordert haben als sie in der Regierung
waren und es hätte in umsetzen können da
haben sie das alles abgelehnt und das
Gegenteil getan jetzt sitzen sie
machtlos in der Opposition und machen
Wahlkampf Getöse vor Landtagswahlen
immer noch mehr als sonst verstehen Sie
dass die Menschen ihn gar nicht mehr
glauben es vollkommen lächerlich ist
wenn die CDU CSU ankommt und ein hartes
Grenzregime fordert und ein hartes
Vorgehen gegen illegale Migration
gefördert ein konsequenten Grenzschutz
von alles das was sie hätten machen
können aber nie gemacht haben und die
ganzen Probleme die dieses Land jetzt
hat sind in einem Ausmaß deswegen
entstanden weil sie
2015 die Grenzen nicht geschützt haben
ich weiß sie hören das ungern aber es
wäre unglaublich glaubwürdig wenn Sie
sich einmal hinstellen würden und jetzt
wäre vielleicht ein guter Moment sich
hinzustellen und sich vor der Republik
zu entschuldigen für das Versagen ihrer
Regierungszeit insbesondere seit 2014
und dann sozusagen jetzt wollen wir das
Gegenteil von alledem was wir die ganze
Zeit gemacht haben als wir es
entscheiden können
[Applaus]
verrückt doch ich habe diese Frage
zugelassen weil ich ihn gerne ein Zitat
Vorlesen möchte von früheren
Verfassungsrichter Udo die Fabio der hat
vor kurzem in einem
bemerkenswerten Interview folgendes
gesagt
die AFD ist nicht konservativ auch nicht
nationalkonservativ wenn man ihre
geistige Nähe zum Krieg sehr Putin sieht
er hat ferner gesagt aber die radikale
Wut bewahrt nicht sondern zerstört die
Verbrüderung mit einem Russland dass das
nationale Selbstbestimmungsrecht von
völkernmissachtet kann man kaum anders
werden als einen Verrat an jedem
ehrlichen Patriotismus nennen sie sich
nicht mehr patriorten das ist meine
Botschaft an sie
[Applaus]
Bundesfinanzminister die haben gestern
in ihrer Haushaltsrede Bezug genommen
auf die 29 sonder Haushalte und haben
mich dabei direkt angesprochen Herr
Bundesfinanzminister und haben gesagt
die wären ja schon aus Zeiten von Theo
Waigel um zumindestens zum Teil zur
Zeiten von Theo Waigel um den Versuch
ihres arguments um den Versuch ihres
arguments zu komplettieren möchte ich
sagen es geht schlichtweg um das Volumen
Herr Bundesfinanzminister und da muss
man noch gar nicht so weit zurückgehen
bis zu theoriegel im Jahr 2019 was ja
ihr Referenz ja ist der war der Anteil
des Haushalts des Bundeshaushalts aus
den sogenannten Sondervermögen 5
Milliarden Euro in ihrem jetzigen
Entwurf ist der Anteil des Haushalt aus
Sondervermögen nahezu 95 Milliarden Euro
und das ist der Unterschied 5 Milliarden
zu 95 Milliarden fast 20 Prozent ihres
Haushalts wird aus Sondervermögen
bestücken und das ist was anderes als
solide Haushaltsführung
was sie gerade tun sie nennen das
konsolidieren ich nenne das Kaschieren
wir stellen fest dass es vom
Bundesrechnungshof jetzt auch einen
neuen Begriff gibt die echte
Nettokreditaufnahme wird eingeführt ganz
offensichtlich weil es auch eine
verschleierte
Nettokreditaufnahme gibt sie reden
offiziell von 16,6 Milliarden die echte
nette Kreditaufnahme nach Rechnungshof
sind
85,7 Milliarden das heißt der
Bundesfinanzminister wenn sie fünf Euro
Schulden aufnehmen dann stellen sie eine
einen Euro ganz offiziell da vier Euro
wollen sie dort verheimlichen und dann
haben sie darauf hingewiesen dass sie
auch Sondervermögen auflösen das ist
sehr sehr spannend war ein
Sondervermögen dass sie jetzt auflösen
ist das Sondervermögen digitale
Infrastruktur digitale Infrastruktur
gefüllt aus den Erlösen der Vergabe der
mobil das Lizenzen daher kommt das Geld
das in diesem Sondervermögen steckt
bisherige Aufgabe festgeschrieben
Breitbandausbau
mobilfunknetzausbau digitalpakt Schule
dort lagen 4,2 Milliarden Euro sie
nehmen dieses Geld geben davon 2,7
Milliarden Euro an die entsprechenden
Häuser
Verkehrsministerium und
an das Verkehrsministerium und an das
Familienministerium geben Sie 2,7
Milliarden Euro 1,5 Milliarden Euro von
diesem Sondervermögen stellten sie in
die eigene Tasche das steht für diese
Aufgaben nicht mehr zur Verfügung sie
müsste es zukünftig mit Schulden
finanzieren auch das hat der
Rechnungshof deutlich ausgedrückt das
ist das Gegenteil von Fortschritt das
ist Abstieg wenn Sie jetzt bei
Infrastrukturen digitale Minister
so und der Bundeskanzler sie haben auch
für den fleißigen in diesem Land
gesprochen von den Leistungsträgern ich
bin ihnen da sehr sehr dankbar aber
haben sie die Umfrage auch zur Kenntnis
genommen die heute veröffentlicht ist
dass 52 Prozent der Menschen den
Eindruck haben dass sich Arbeit in
Deutschland nicht mehr lohnt die
Überschrift die Schlagzeile heißt heute
der fleißige ist der dumme und der
Bundeskanzler die Verantwortung dafür
tragen sie mit dem Bürgergeld dass die
Bürger diesen Eindruck haben dass der
fleißige der Dumme ist sie sprechen
davon dass es Trost ist der sich hinter
Bevölkerung anstarrt sie sind diejenigen
die die Leute frustrieren mit ihrer
Politik und dafür sorgen dass der
fleißige Dumme ist
und alles
und vielleicht als eindrucksvollen
Beweis dass es eine Reihe von Menschen
gibt die das sind ähnliche Art und Weise
genauso sehen will ich Ihnen mal sagen
wie die Kommunalpolitik und übrigens
auch aus der SPD Kommunalpolitiker
darüber denken der Bürgermeister von
Rottenbuch Markus Bader hat sich
gemeldet in dieser Woche in einem
Interview er sagt dort wörtlich es ist
die Aufgabe der Politik
Rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen aber nicht
zu bevormunden Recht hat der Mann er
schreibt wörtlich mir scheint es
manchmal das wollen besonders linke
Teile der SPD eine neue Spieler hatte
Sozialismus ein einführen und dies durch
die ökologische Hintertür vielleicht hat
er recht das können sie beantworten
wörtlich es ist nicht Aufgabe des
Staates eine
Erziehungsanstalt zu sein über diese
Interview des SPD Bürgermeisters lautet
die Überschrift ich kann die Entwicklung
der SPD nicht mehr mittragen dieser ist
ausgetreten aus der SPD Recht hat der
Mann
Alexander Dobrindt von der CSU
signalisiert trotz heftiger Kritik an
der Ampel die Bereitschaft bei dem von
Scholz vorgeschlagenen Deutschland packt
mitzumachen voraussetzung dafür sei aber
darüber zu reden wie man die
flüchtlingskrise gemeinsam meistere dazu
gehöre auch die Maghreb-Staaten zu
sicheren Herkunftsländer zu machen mit
den Grünen dürfte das kaum machbar sein
eine Pfeife so ähnlich war es einen
Ordnungsruf
[Applaus]
Mütze nicht sein der
SPD-Fraktionsvorsitzende
[Applaus]
alles gut
in der Tat es bleibt die Präsidentin
aber wegen der wegen des Respekts frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zu Recht hat der Bundeskanzler
den russischen Überfall auf die Ukraine
als seitenwende bezeichnet und nicht
allein die Tat und das Ausmaß sondern
auch die Folgen für die internationale
Ordnung werden sich tief in die Welt
einbrennen und der Krieg in der Ukraine
davon bin ich fest überzeugt und wir
haben öfter hier im Plenum darüber
gesprochen beschleunigt die Neuordnung
der Welt und deswegen ist diese
Feststellung des Bundeskanzlers richtig
und dennoch glaube ich dass es gut ist
den Begriff der Zeiten Wände Weile eben
zu wertvoll zu zentral ist auch mit
anderen Herausforderungen gleichzeitig
zu verbinden und sie gibt es eben in
ganz unterschiedlichen
gesellschaftspolitischen
europapolitischen internationalen
Bereich da ist das Klima die Wirtschaft
die Digitalisierung die Pandemie und ich
sage es auch ganz bewusst weil sich doch
vieles im Leben der Menschen ändert auch
das öffentliche und private miteinander
und deswegen sage ich ja wir leben und
arbeiten in vielen Zeiten wenden meine
Damen und Herren und alleine eine
Herausforderung wer für viele Menschen
schon eine große Herausforderung und sie
erkennen sie als Belastung und deswegen
sage ich auch frei auch hier im
Deutschen Bundestag würde wahrscheinlich
eine zwei drei Zeiten wenden reichen für
eine gesamte Legislaturperiode deswegen
ist das gesamte dem wir uns stellen
müssen natürlich etwas was verunsichert
auch mich persönlich und deswegen
verstehe ich auch wenn die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger sich ins Private manchmal
zurückziehen doch sozusagen ihren
Schutzraum identifizieren der Psychologe
Stefan Grünewald hatte am Anfang seiner
großen Studie Anfang letzten Jahres
gesagt das persönliche Zuversicht der
deutschen uns Vertrauen in Politik aber
ich sage auch gleichzeitig in Wirtschaft
und selbst in die Gesellschaft schwindet
und deswegen ist es gut wenn wir auch
etwas bisschen bescheidener vielleicht
manchmal auch in dieser Debatte
formulieren würden deswegen stelle ich
mich meine Damen und Herren dieser
Skepsis zumal und auch das sage ich
offen die Spitzen der Koalition in den
vergangenen Monaten kein gutes Bild
abgegeben haben ja wir müssen besser
werden handwerklich kommunikativ und ich
sage auch sehr deutlich die Antworten
können unterschiedlich sein aber am Ende
gerade auch für diese Koalition steht am
Ende ein gemeinsames Ganzes was auch nur
diese politische Verbindung in dieser
Legislaturperiode erreichen kann
deswegen bin ich auch so stolz
dass wir vor zwei Jahren diese
Verbindung eingegangen sind meine Damen
und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen miteinander können wir
erfolgreich sein weil nur in dieser
Konstellation die Herausforderungen
beantwortet werden in keiner anderen
politischen Konstellation schauen Sie
sich im Deutschen Bundestag an wäre es
möglich den Umbau der Arbeit und der
Wirtschaft zu Klimaneutralität ein neuen
Rechtsrahmen der sich speist aus
Liberalität aus einem
Verantwortungsbewusstsein für das Klima
aber gleichzeitig auch der soziale
Rückhalt zu verankern das macht diese
Koalition aus und deswegen sage ich auch
dafür steht meine Fraktion liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ja und da hilft keine hauruck-rede nicht
mit dem mit der Faust auf den Tisch
schlagen allein weiter was genau so
weiterhilft ist eine gute Voraussetzung
nämlich eine verlässliche und auch
unaufgeregte parlamentarische Arbeit und
ich sage das sehr selbstbewusst dass
Gebäude Energiegesetz steht für diese
verlässliche und unaufgeregte Arbeit ein
Gesetzentwurf der in mühevoller
Kleinarbeit von den Abgeordneten vom
Kopf auf die Füße gestellt worden ist
ich darf das hier
so sagen auch als selbstbewusster
Parlamentarier ich hätte es mir nicht
gewünscht zumindestens diesen
Gesetzentwurf in dieser Form so hier im
Deutschen Bundestag zu sehen aber das
kann man sich nicht aussuchen aber wir
haben es eben geschafft die Grundlagen
zu verändern die kommunale wärmeplanung
wird jetzt damit verkoppelt und beides
itt am
1.1.2024 in Kraft die Zeiträume sind
geändert worden und gleichzeitig eben
auch die Hilfen ganz konzentriert auf
diejenigen orientiert weil nämlich
Klimaschutz meine Damen und Herren und
dafür sind wir in dieser Koalition
angetreten und deswegen hat auch meine
Partei ja gesagt Klimaschutz müssen sich
alle leisten können und genauso ist das
Gebäude Energiegesetz auch konzentriert
deswegen
souveräne und selbstbewusste Parlamente
in Europa in den Ländern aber eben auch
im Bund das sind die Architekten und
gleichzeitig die Handwerker die auch für
diese zeitenwände gut ausgerüstet sind
ja wir dürfen die Herausforderung das
habe ich gesagt nicht kleinreden und ich
glaube die Bürgerinnen und Bürger spüren
diesen Druck deswegen wissen Sie um die
strukturellen Gründe auch von denen
Deutschland steht natürlich ist die
weltweite Konjunktur ein Problem für ein
so exportorientiertes Land wie
Deutschland aber das ist nicht die
Exportabhängigkeit sondern es steht für
Qualität es steht für den Erfindergeist
auch Deutschland und genau in dieser
Richtung müssen wir denken die Chancen
letztlich erkennen und deswegen sagen
wir ja auch wir wollen den
Arbeitskräftemangel und den
Fachkräftemangel gemeinsam
angehen und gleichzeitig eben auch
wissen dass es neue wirtschaftliche
Zentren in der Welt gibt es bleibt nicht
so wie es gewesen ist wie meine
Generation es vorgefunden hat wir müssen
diesen Weg verändern wir müssen ihnen
mitgehen und meine Damen und Herren das
will meine Fraktion und ich bin auch der
festen Überzeugung auch diese Koalition
und deswegen
sage ich auch ja
wenn wir auf die Realitäten ganz genau
schauen und auch ein bisschen
bescheidener formulieren dann akzeptiere
ich auch dass auch uns
Versäumnisse aus der Vergangenheit
vorgeworfen werden aber ich will jetzt
mal einfach sagen dass betrifft dann
auch alle natürlich gebe ich zu dass wir
manchmal nicht die Kraft gehabt haben
für das auch Mehrheiten zu schaffen was
so dringend notwendig gewesen ist und
ich war selbst im Kanzleramt im März
damals als wir über Klimapolitik
gesprochen haben morgens früh um 5 Uhr
haben wir darum gerungen haben wir darum
gerungen endlich auch bei den Windrädern
bei der erneuerbaren Energie Wege zu
finden und da ist nicht nur in dieser
Koalition blockiert worden wir hatten
auch keine Unterstützung aus dem
Bundesländern gehabt deswegen sage ich
mal alles das was dem einzelnen hier
vorgeworfen wird das betrifft das ganze
und deswegen ist es gut dass diese
Koalition endlich diesen Wandel endlich
diese Wende macht und deswegen sage ich
sehr deutlich selbstbewusste Parlamente
und meine Fraktion werden daran
mitwirken und wir haben etwa sehrreicht
wir haben etwas erreicht in den zwei
Jahren die Halbzeitbilanz ist gut wir
haben wichtige Etappen gefunden
bleibende Veränderungen soziale Rechte
geschaffen insbesondere für
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer und
deren Familien ich nenne das Wohngeld
nicht nur dass es erhöht worden ist
sondern dass es ausgeweitet worden ist
und das Bürgergeld der Kollege Merz
jeder fünfte ist auf das Bürgergeld
deswegen angewiesen weil er zu wenig
Einkommen hat darum geht es in diesem
Land weil zu ringen zu geringen bezahlt
wird und sie an den Bürgergeld
zugestimmt aber die Mindestlohn nicht da
dreht sich etwas um und ich finde das
ist
verantwortungsvoll wenn wir so handeln
und auch das Kindergeld da hat ja
offensichtlich niemand zugehört bis in
die Kreise die sich in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten abgemüht haben das
haben wir mit sieben Milliarden Euro
angepasst
250 Euro jedes Kind ab dem ersten Kind
bekommt dies und dann noch den
Kinderzuschlag das ist etwas um das
Plateau für die Kindergrundsicherung zu
finden und das hat das Parlament gemacht
der Haushaltsgesetzgeber und das war
richtig liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Energiesicherheit Digitalisierung
Arbeits- und Fachkräfte aber eben auch
die Tarifautonomie Stärken es geht jetzt
um Mitbestimmung in den nächsten Monaten
wenn wir hier im Deutschen Bundestag
darüber debattieren was ist mit dem
Betriebsverfassungsgesetz Mitbestimmung
ist eine wichtige
Verbindung in einem Staat der sich
Sozialstaat nennt und das kostet nicht
sondern das gibt etwas das gibt nämlich
Sicherheit den Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmern und es gibt Sicherheit den
Unternehmen weil sie wissen alle die
doch in diesem Unternehmen sind arbeiten
Hand in Hand und genau das ist das was
Deutschland als Sozialmodell auch
anbietet und deswegen
Herr Bundeskanzler ich kann für meine
Fraktion sagen dass wir an diesem
deutschlandpackt mitwirken werden und
wenn der dobrin für die gesamte Fraktion
gesprochen hat Kollege Dobrindt dann
nehme ich das gerne auf dass sie daran
mitwirken wollen und wir haben es ja
nicht nur in ihre Richtung als Fraktion
gesagt sondern weil wir auch die
Bundesländer brauchen weil wir doch auch
die Kommunen brauchen darum geht's und
deswegen sage ich ja das Angebot des
Bundeskanzlers für den Deutschland Pakt
ist richtig und lassen wir es anpackten
ich glaube das ist ein guter Schritt
auch in den kommenden zwei Jahren dieser
Legislaturperiode liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und wenn ich gleichzeitig sage
in konjunkturellen Schwächephasen der
Finanzminister und an die ganze
Bundesregierung auch gesagt so muss ich
bekennen das Sozialdemokraten
Sozialdemokraten die nur 160-jährigen
Geschichte Fest der Auffassung gewesen
sind das antizyklische Wirtschafts- und
Finanzpolitik aber gleichzeitig eben
auch eine faire Lastenteilung von
Einkommen und Vermögen in dieser
Gesellschaft zusammengehören und nicht
akzeptiere dass es unterschiedliche
Meinungen gibt aber ich will ihnen sagen
ich glaube die Beispiele aus der Welt
die Treffen eben zu dass genau die
Staaten die beides verknüpfen
antizyklische Wirtschafts-
[Applaus]
genau die USA die beiden Regierung das
tut wir reden hier immer über den
Inflation reduction Act aber das darum
geht es überhaupt nicht nur da geht es
auch um soziale Gerechtigkeit einer
demokratischen Regierung in ihrem Land
wenn sie auf Gesundheitspolitik achten
wenn sie auf die ärmeren Menschen achten
und genau diese Verknüpfung glaube ich
ist gut anzubieten deswegen muss ich da
selbstbewusst für uns sagen aber ich
akzeptiere auch andere Meinung aber das
ist doch unsere Stärke in dieser
Regierung dass wir beides miteinander
verknüpfen können und genauso wollen wir
in den nächsten Wochen meine Damen und
Herren auch den Haushalt gestalten und
ich glaube es ist richtig dass wir ein
wachstumschancengesetz auf den Weg
bringen lassen wir Finanzminister
gemeinsam überlegen was die Hinweise ich
nenne es jetzt mal positiv Hinweise von
den Ländern möglicherweise auch noch aus
einem guten ein besseren Gesetzentwurf
machen
wenn wir insbesondere über
Innovationsförderung reden die Frage der
Belastung der Kommunen da sollten wir
uns auch noch mal darauf hinbewegen aber
gleichzeitig eine aktive
Wirtschaftspolitik betreiben die den
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmern und
ihren Familien gut tun deswegen sage ich
sehr deutlich auch für meine Fraktion
das was in der letzten Zeit sich in
Deutschland festgesetzt hat und manchmal
habe ich so sagen ich finde es manchmal
eine deutsche mediale Krankheit dass wir
nur in extremen diskutieren dass wir uns
plötzlich so
so schlecht reden die Lichter die
Lichter und die Heizung im letzten Jahr
sind nicht ausgegangen Salzgitter
baut das erste Stahlwerk mit grünen
Stahl ThyssenKrupp kommt hinterher neue
Batterie Firmen werden in Deutschland
angesiedelt ich meine Damen und Herren
kann mich dem Eindruck nicht erwehren
diese gesamte Diskussion ob wissentlich
und willentlich oder einfach nur indem
man nicht genau hinschaut bereitet
wieder einer Debatte die ich aus
Deutschland kenne Vorschub nämlich den
Sozialstaat zum Sündenbock zu machen und
da sage ich ganz klar hier sagen
Sozialdemokraten und Sozialdemokraten
nein auch wir haben eine Schmerzgrenze
meine Damen und Herren und deswegen ich
glaube
ich glaube es ist gut
gemeinsam zusammen zu wirken für die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer für
die Familien für dieses Land und
deswegen sage ich sehr deutlich es lohnt
sich in den nächsten Wochen miteinander
über vieles noch zu reden vielen Dank
so wir blenden uns jetzt hier aus aus
einer wirklich lebhaften Debatte
allerdings auch mit nachdenklichen Tönen
die gerade eben der Kanzler hat einen
deutschland-pakt vorgeschlagen für mehr
Tempo in diesem Lande um den Stillstand
zu beenden die Opposition signalisiert
Zusammenarbeit allerdings unter
bestimmten Voraussetzungen viel
Diskussionsstoff also für die nächsten
Wochen ich bedanke mich für Ihr
Interesse und sage Tschüss bis zum
nächsten Mal